c'est le grand rendez-vous qu'Emmanuel
Macron avait donné aux Français il aura
elle aura lieu ce soir cette grande
conférence de presse d'Emmanuel Macron
d'ici une quinzaine de minutes mais
pourquoi faire cette grande conférence
de presse à quoi faut-il s'attendre et
bien on va discuter de tout ça pendant
une dizaine de minutes avant que cette
conférence de presse débute et pour en
parler je suis avec Luc gras qui est
politologue bonjour Luc merci d'être
avec nous aujourd'hui bonjour j'invite
j'invite no internautes bien sûr à à
poser leurs questions on répond au mieux
comme d' habitude vous n'hésitez pas
vous êtes déjà nombreux à nous rejoindre
je le vois sur Youtube et sur le site du
Figaro Luc une première question un peu
générale mais à quoi faut-il s'attendre
pour cette première pour cette première
pour cette grande conférence de presse
qu'on nous annonce depuis un petit
moment j'espère qu'il faut s'attendre à
quelque chose car c'est tout l'intérêt
du président de la République mais même
du pays d'avoir ce soir par le biais de
cette conférence de presse qui ne sera
d'ailleurs que la 3 conférence de presse
organisée à l'initiative d'Emmanuel
Macron depuis
2017 et bien qu'il vienneent avec ce
qu'on pourrait dire des des biscuits à
présenter aux Français il on peut
s'attendre à ce qu'il délivre un message
fort avec une ligne directrice ceci
illustré par des annonces qui pourrai
être surprenantes en tout cas les
Français attendent par exemple en
matière de de référendum et puis pour
cela une stratégie car le président
reste toujours sous la difficulté de
cette majorité relative qui est présente
à l'Assemblée nationale depuis 2022 oui
bien sûr et on va et on va reparler ce
qui est prévu c'est un propos
limininaire d'une vingtaine de minutes
par le chef de l'État puis ensuite une
une pardon une des questions réponses
qui peuvent durer et on connaît le
président de la République ça peut durer
un moment il y a pas de de d'heure de
fin
encore alors effectivement les
informations dont on dispose c'est un
propos liminaire mais vous savez que le
président aime ces propos liminaire donc
il devrait durer 20 minutes après quoi
il se soumet à cet exercice et et il
faut souligner à ce stade que c'est un
un exercice salutaire en démocratie que
euh ces conférences de presse alors j'ai
lu que doquin disait que c'était un peu
asbine c'était le général de Gaul et
Georges Pompidou qui pratiquait surtout
cela d'une part c'est pas totalement
vrai parce que François Hollande
lui-même à euh je crois pratiquer les
conférences de presse à six reprises et
que la conférence de presse est tout à
fait intéressante parce qu'elle met le
président dans une forme d'insécurité
puisqu'il ne connaît pas à l'avance
toutes les questions et donc ça montre
sa capacité de réactivité son fond sur
un exercice qui n'est certes pas facile
h alors il y a des critiques aussi qui
parlent du retour de de l'ORTF avec
cette ce président qui récupère
finalement le prime time de de la
télévision à son
profit alors moi je parlerai pas de
retour à l'ORTF donc plus personne dans
les jeunes générations ne sait ce que
c'était mais plutôt de retour au peuple
parce que la conférence de presse c'est
un retour au peuple via les journalistes
qui sont des personnes venu de tous les
bords et qui posent des questions je
pense qu' en démocratie la conférence de
presse est quelque chose de
d'intéressant elle met le président
devant des questionnements beaucoup plus
difficiles et donc qui montre sa densité
intellectu et politique alors que dans
les émissions préorganisées il connaît
déjà les questions les choses comme ça
donc ça peut être intéressant et
beaucoup plus vivifiant pour le débat
démocratique et on suivra ça Rouya qui
nous demande il va parler de quoi et
bien c'est la question qu'on se pose de
quoi va-t-il parler lu gras lors de
cette conférence de presse Emmanuel
Macron à votre avis alors le président
de la République va certainement faire
comme toujours forme de bilan de ce qui
s'est passé pour dire au français qu'
les a compris euh et donc revenir
probablement sur euh ce qui les les
évidemment la les propositions sur les
retraites les lois la loi sur les
retraites et également la loi sur
l'immigration il peut pas ne pas parler
de ça à un moment il va assez vite
enchaîner sur les initiatives qu'il a
pris avec ses vœux annonateur de cette
conférence de presse mais aussi cette
nouveauté de la nomination de Gabriel
hatal et d'autres aussi qui sont
peut-être moins innovants avec le retour
de certains politiques anciens et puis
peut-être dresser des perspectives et on
nous annonce qu'il y aura justement des
nouveautés est-ce que ce sera du domaine
de la vie démocratique pour qu'il y ait
une meilleure vie démocratique comme par
exemple en proposant des initiattiv des
initiatives en matière de référendum
peut-être h effectivement nous nous
verrons cela réponse dans un peu peu
moins de 10 minutes maintenant je salue
Marie posa je salue Kossi qui nous qui
nous rejoignent ruya merci d'avoir lu ma
question mais allez-y n'hésitez pas bien
sûr à à à poser vos questions comme je
vous le disais euh on on on a parlé des
des des des thèmes abordés il va falloir
qu'il soit extrêmement précis le
président alors que des images l'image
en direct nous recevons en ce moment
l'image en direct de la chaise du
président de la République euh quand il
il il parlera d'ici euh qu'en
pensez-vous Luc
gr je crois qu'effectivement ce soir il
y a un rendez-vous avec les français
puisque vous savez que pas moins de six
médias nationaux suivent les quatre
chaînes d'information plus évidemment le
Figaro live et puis plus les les deux
grandes télés nationales TF1 et France 2
donc il y a un rendez-vous avec les
Français et et l'enjeu pour lui et tout
tout d'abord celui de la crédibilité
est-ce que la parole du président
impacte encore sur les Français les
études d'opinion au cours des dernières
années ont montré que les Français
étaient de moins en moins susceptible
d'être convaincu par le Président c'est
à lui de prouver le contraire ce soir h
on se rappelle Emmanuel Macron fait
souvent des des des grandes annonces
pour se relancer il y avait eu le grand
débat par exemple est-ce que c'est cette
conférence de presse c'est une vraie
bonne idée selon vous moi je pense qu'en
terme démocratique c'est une bonne idée
parce que les questions fuseront d'un
peu partout et peuvent justement
permettre de sortir des sentiers battus
après c'est vrai que Emmanuel Macron
nous a habitué par le passé à faire des
annonces ne seraitce qu'au tout début en
annonçant le monde nouveau que le
système était sclérosé et que il voulait
apporter du neuf 2017 il dit apporter du
neuf 2024 rachidti revient au
gouvernement il y a quand même des
questions là-dessus donc c'est vraiment
important pour lui de montrer comment
aujourd'hui il va passer des effets
d'annonce à du concret il y a eu aussi
le CNR le le Conseil national de la
rénovation qui se voulait inspirer par
le Conseil National de la Résistance on
peut pas jouer avec l'histoire on peut
pas jouer avec les mots comme il l'a
fait jusqu'à présent sans un moment
donner rendez-vous au français pour
faire du concret s'il le fait il relance
son deuxème quinina s'il le fait pas il
il continue à avoir une relation avec
les
Français inspiré par le doute de la plus
grande partie des Français h on a on a
Mathieu l rouge dans les commentaires
qui demande quels seront les thèmes
abordés alors on imagine qu'il y en aura
beaucoup vu que ça va durer un moment
mais principalement selon vous quel vont
être justement ces thèmes abordés alors
les thèmes abordés il y a évidemment on
peut pas faire autrement que d'aborder
le sujet numéro 1 des qui préoccupe les
Français c'est le pouvoir d'achat donc
il va nous redire que la France en
matière de chômage a fait des progrès ce
qui est vrai mais ce n'est pas suffisant
parce qu'il faut que les Français dans
leur bultin de paye et surtout à la fin
du mois se rendre compte que l'économie
allant mieux il faut qu'elle profite au
français donc le la question du pouvoir
d'achat est absolument essentielle et ce
sera le premier sujet le 2uxème sujet il
va essayer de faire un petit peu avaler
la la les Fasti qu' ont été la loi sur
les retraites et la évidemment la loi
sur l'immigration ceci dit il y a quand
même une suspension pour l'instant par
rapport à la Loi de l'immigration sur
l'immigration cont tenu du fait que le
Conseil constitutionnel peut entièrement
détricoter les mesures importante ou pas
donc là ilura ça et puis il va
évidemment aborder aussi les questions
de la politique international où il est
semble-t-il euh plus à l'aise il va nous
parler évidemment des grands enjeux du
monde du danger euh que comporte le
monde aujourd'hui avec la montée des
régimes autoritaires et euh et et la
guerre à nos portes puisqu à moins de
3000 km d'ici on le sait l'Ukraine est
sous l'attaque et la menace de la Russie
de Monsieur Poutine h alors nous avons
dans les dans les commentaires alors ça
c'est plutôt une question qui est pour
moi PCAS qui nous demande un journaliste
de la maison sur place oui les
journaliste du Figaro ce sont bien
évidemment sur place ils poseront même
peut-être une question s'ils sont
choisis si puisque vous savez comment ça
se passe lors de ces de cet événement il
y a beaucoup de gens beaucoup de gens
qui veulent poser des questions on parit
de concret tout à l'heure est-ce qu'on
peut imaginer Emmanuel Macron annoncer
euh la fin d'une taxe par exemple une
baisse d'impôt ça ça concerne vraiment
les gens finalement alors c'est ce
serait probablement une très bonne idée
pour aller toucher les les classes
moyennes en particulier hein puisque
Gabriel Atal lui-même avait avait dit
que c'était l'un des objectifs de son
action c'était
d'alléger la charge avec bien sûr
l'initiative de de Monsieur le Maire sur
les classes moyennes ce serait une très
bonne idée le problème c'est
qu'actuellement au gouvernement tout le
monde n'est pas d'accord sur les
initiatives à prendre dans la matière et
que la proposition de baisser comme le
le préconise le rassemblement national
certaines taxes n n'est pas suivie donc
baisser les impôts oui mais toute la
question est de savoir comment h
effectivement euh on on suivra ça on
nous demande voilà on on nous fait dans
les commentaires plusie plusieurs thème
par par exemple la grève des
agriculteurs qui est un qui qui qui un
sujet qu'on a vu aussi beaucoup en ce
moment cela va dépendre donc des
questions il y aura aussi sûrement des
questions concernant Gabriel Atal son
nouveau Premier ministre et ce choix de
premier
ministre il y aura certainement des des
questions et et ça pourrait être
intéressant que les questions
s'orientent sur la diarchie comment
Emmanuel Macron euh conçoit la relation
du président de la République avec ce
tout nouveau jeune premier ministre
est-ce qu'il va lui laisser suffisamment
d'espace ce serait son intérêt mais
est-ce que sa nature va pas l'emporter
symboliquement c'est assez assez
marquant que il décide de faire une
conférence de presse aujourd'hui à
quelques jours de la déclaration de
politique générale de Gabriel Atal
devant les représ représentant de la
nation à l'Assemblée nationale donc
c'est vrai que là il y a un vrai sujet
comment il entend répartir les rôles
puisque le président étant la clé de
vous des institutions beaucoup dépend de
lui dans la répartition des tâches oui
il risque de de de lui damer le pion en
fait on l'entendra finalement plus tant
que ça gabrielal parce qu' alors il va
parler a priori dans maintenant 15 jours
donc il va prendre son temps mais
finalement c'était à lui de parler
c'était pas au président de la
République normalement écoutez depuis la
nomination Gabriel Atal on voit bien
comment se pose les choses la
composition du gouvernement elle est
certainement venue de d'Emmanuel Macron
même si voilà c'est le président de la
République qui nomme sur proposition du
Premier ministre le le le gouvernement
on voit bien que là c'est été tout a été
fait par le Président de la République
aujourd'hui cette conférence de presse
enlève un peu de la lumière à son
premier ministre mais on peut peut-être
faire confiance à son premier ministre
pour lorsqu'il s'exprimera à son tour
développer un discours propre et de
qualité pour pouvoir quand même exister
h les membres du gouvernement qui
arrivent vous voyez Bruno Leem rachti
Éric dupomorti on a vu aussi Amélie oua
Castera la nouvelle ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui commence son
mandat par quelques polémiqu et qui ce
qui ne doit pas non plus arranger
forcément Emmanuel Macron alors c'est
sûr parce que derrière la personne qu'il
ne faut évidemment pas attaquer à
dominem la PvE madame oua Castera mais
c'est vrai qu'il y a une symbolique que
qui a été vraiment malheureuse pour le
moins de d'être ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de s'en sortir très mal par
rapport à la
justification de la scolarisation de ces
enfants dans un établissement privé si
up soit-il et surtout up soit-il donc
elle commence dans des dans des dans des
situations très compliquées d'autant
plus que le débat depuis sa nomination
et que c'est ces ces hyper ministères
qui regroupent l'éducation nationale le
sports les Jeux Olympiques on voit pas
comment une personne normalement
formatée pourra être révolutionnaire
comme dirait le président de la
République et initier beaucoup de choses
dans dans autant de domaines à la
fois pour s'en sortir probablement
qu'elle devra être plus gestionnaire que
révolutionnaire h alors on a des
questions aussi on demande s'il y aura
des questions internationales forcément
il y en aura puisque il y a des
centaines de journalistes qui sont
présents à cette conférence de presse
donc on parlera aussi des sujets de
l'international vous avez vu Amélie W
cterra sur ces images Gabriel Atal on en
a parlé et les prises de guerre on peut
les appeler comme ça d'Emmanuel Macron
pour ce gouvernement Catherine vautterin
et rachidti qui viennent plutôt de
l'ancien monde que du nouveau monde
lugras mais je vous le disais tout à
l'heure c'est c'est ce qui est très on
peut dire chocant dans cette évolution
c'est que 2017 c'était le Nouveau Monde
2024 c'est le retour des des des vieux
mamouths et ça c'est c'est c'est en
terme de vous savez en politique et en
communication politique surtout il faut
que les choses soient lisibles et là de
deux informations contraires viennent
complètement s'entrechoquer dans le
message du président est-il toujours
porteur de 2017 il nous dit que oui
est-il toujours porteur de de cette
initiative et il fait revenir rachidti
assez curieux alors que le public se
lève le président de la République va le
VO merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
on se retrouve à la fin de cette cette
conférence de presse pour débriefer tout
ça merci d'avoir été avec nous restez
avec nous bien évid puisque c'est
maintenant que tout commence
àite Monsieur le Premier Ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
mesdames et messieurs bienvenue dans
cette maison permettez-moi avant toute
chose de vous souhaiter à nouveau une
belle heureuse année et de la souhaiter
à nouveau à nos compatriotes qui nous
suivent ce
soir
je ne reviendrai pas dans mon propos
introductif sur ce que j'ai pu évoquer
les fiertés des grands événements de
l'année qui s'ouvre pour donc 2024 que
j'ai déjà détaillé le 31 décembre
dernier ni sur les grands sujets de
politique internationale les sujets les
plus institutionnels nous pourrons y
revenir dans le cadre des questions qui
seront les vôtres mais après 6 ans et
demi d'action au service des
Français j'ai tenu à vous retrouver ce
moment décisif pour dire au pays d'où
nous venons et où nous
allons alors d'où nous venons parce que
les dernières années nous avons
évidemment subi des crises pandémie
retour de la guerre j' reviendrai et
cetera mais nous avons collectivement
cherché à suivre une ligne claire
libérer les énergies protéger les
Français unir la
nation et nous pouvons compter sur des
forces se retrouver force économique et
et social nous avons créé plus de 2
millions d'emplois ouvert plus de 300
usines réussi un chemin à la fois de
création d'activités et de décarbonation
de notre
économie force républicaines aussi de
l'état retrouvé de ceux qui les servent
nous avons massivement réinvesti dans
nos armées pour nos policiers nos
gendarmes pour notre justice mais aussi
pour notre école et notre santé pour ne
citer que quelques exemples ce qui fait
qu'au moment où je vous parle oui nous
sommes mieux armés qu'il y a 6 ans et
demi
mais où
allons-nous et nous le vivons
tous au fond le monde d'hier est en
train de
s'effacer l'ordre international que nous
connaissions est
bousculé la guerre revient sur le sol
européen avec l'agression russe en
Ukraine il y a près de 2 ans maintenant
la guerre revient au Proche Orient avec
l'attaque terroriste du Hamas le 7ctobre
dernier qui a plongé toute la région
dans la guerre nous vivons
nous le savons aussi la crise du modèle
démocratique en France en Europe et dans
beaucoup d'autres pays la crise
climatique provoque des inquiétudes et
poussent à des transitions qui divisent
parfois nos pays mais on le voit partout
là aussi en Europe et l'irruption de
nouvelles technologies bouleverse
beaucoup de nos
repères pourtant au moment où notre pays
est à la fois menacé par les tensions du
monde et ces division de l'intérieur que
nous avons encore vécu ces derniers mois
et sur lesquelles nous reviendrons
peut-être
je suis convaincu que nous avons tous
les atouts pour
réussir convaincu que nous n avons pas
fini avec notre histoire de progrès et
que nos enfants vivront mieux demain que
nous vivons aujourd'hui et c'est pour
faire face à ces défis et à ce moment
très précis du mandat que mont confié
les Français que j'ai voulu nommer un
nouveau
gouvernement pourquoi ce gouvernement le
plus resserré et le plus jeune de
l'histoire de la 5e
République parce que cette époque de
crise que je décris rapidement suppose
avant tout audace action et
efficacité dans les mois dans les années
à venir se décidera le destin des
prochaines générations c'est tout
l'enjeu c'est tout notre
défi voilà pourquoi nous sommes là voilà
pourquoi démocrates écologistes
républicains se rassemblent autour d'un
même projet pour agir service des
Français et au fond avec une ligne
simple pour que la France reste la
France pour que la France demeure cette
nation du bon sens de résistance et des
lumières le Premier ministre aura
détaillé les jours qui viennent après un
travail avec les ministres de son
gouvernement force politique et tout
particulièrement sa majorité au
Parlement et les groupes aussi au Sénat
le calendrier de l'action qui est la
sienne et l'exposera lors de sa
déclaration de politique générale je
veux ici essayer de de dire le sens
profond de cette action rendre au fond
la France plus forte et plus juste c'est
ça le combat des prochaines années et
au-delà dans lequel nous devons conduire
la France pour les décennies qui
viennent la France sera plus forte dans
ce monde de bouleversement si nous
sommes d'abord plus
unis si nous réapprenons à partager des
valeurs une culture commune le sens du
respect dans les salles de classe dans
la rue dans les transports comme dans
les
commerces c'est pourquoi comme je l'ai
indiqué le 31 décembre dernier lors de
mes vœux nous engagerons un réarmement
civique chaque génération de français
doit apprendre ce que la République veut
dire une histoire des devoirs des droit
une langue un
imaginaire le sens profond du respect et
de l'engagement et cela dès
l'enfance en renforçant le soutien et
l'exigence vis-à-vis des parents en
reprenant aussi le contrôle de nos
écrans qui trop souvent enferment là où
il devrait libérer sur la base de
recommandation que font les experts que
j'ai réuni la semaine dernière nous
déterminerons le bon usage des écrans
pour nos enfants dans les familles à la
maison comme en classe parce qu'il en va
de l'avenir de nos sociétés et de nos
démocraties
à l'école ensuite depuis 2017 nous avons
entamé un choc des savoirs le retour des
fondamentaux l'enseignement le
dédoublement des classes et nous allons
le poursuivre avec des maîtres mieux
formés mieux payés une rénovation des
programmes des évaluations en chaque
niveau dès la rentrée
2024 l'instruction civique sera refondé
son volume horaire sera doublé une heure
par semaine dès la 5e avec en appui les
grands textes fondateurs de la
nation mais l'école dans laquelle la
confiance aussi se déploie où on forge
pleinement et on exprime les talents de
chacun doit donner une place à la
culture et au
sport c'est pourquoi nous avons instauré
la demi-heure de sport quotidienne en
primaire et 2 heures supplémentaire par
semaine au
collège audelà de cela l'éducation
artistique et culturelle que nous avons
déployé dans nos écoles depuis
maintenant un peu plus de 6 ans va se
renforcer comme pour la musique et les
arts plastiques je souhaite que le
théâtre devienne un passage obligé au
collège dès la rentrée
prochaine parce que cela donne confiance
cela apprend l'oralité le contact au
grand texte et parce que la France est
aussi une histoire un patrimoine qui se
transmet et qui unit l'histoire de l'art
retrouvera sa place à la rentrée
prochaine au collège et au
lycée la tenue unique qui a donné lieu à
tant de débats ces derniers mois dans
notre pays et qui efface les inégalités
entre les familles en même temps qu'elle
crée les conditions du respect sera
expérimenté dès cette année dans une
centaine
d'établissements tous
volontaires cette expérimentation sera
évaluée
méthodiquement et sur la base des
résultats s'ils sont concluants nous la
généraliserons en
2026 siteront dans chaque collège et
dans chaque lycée dès la fin de cette
année une cérémonie de remise des
diplômes rite républicain d'unité de
fierté et de
reconnaissance la famille et l'école au
fond pour faire des républicains en même
temps que pour transmettre des
savoirs mais avoir une France plus forte
c'est aussi assurer l'ordre l'ordre en
contrôlant mieux nos
frontières grâce au TEX Tex que nous
avons pu voter en France comme ceux que
nous avons voté au niveau européen et la
poursuite aussi de ce que nous avons
renforcé ces dernières années l'ordre en
lutant contre les incivilités grâce à un
doublement de la de la présence
policière dans nos rues c'est le cœur de
la stratégie annoncé il y a quelques
années à roubé par les emplois créés et
les réformes conduites l'ordre en
luttant contre la
drogue qui ces dernières années se
déploie pas simplement dans les grandes
villes mais dans des villes moyennes qui
la connaissaient moins parfois même dans
des villes
grâce à la multiplication des opérations
place net frappant les narcotrafiquants
qui se conduiront dans toutes les
catégories de villees et nous allons
accroître le rythme à partir de la
semaine prochaine 10 opérations de ce
type seront conduites chaque
semaine l'ordre en luttant aussi contre
l'islam radical en appliquant
méthodiquement la loi que nous avons
voté il y a maintenant un peu plus de 2
ans qui nous a permis de fermer des
associations des établissements qui ne
respectai pas les règles de la
République qui nous a permettre de nous
a permis aussi de mettre fin depuis le
1er janvier au système des imames
détachés nous tiendrons cette ligne de
fermetaire
républicaine la France sera plus forte
aussi si elle produit
davantage la pandémie a montré que pour
nombre de biens essentiels les
médicaments par exemple nous dépendions
trop souvent de
l'étranger et les solutions
technologiques de demain particulier
pour la croissance verte ou le numérique
risquent d'être produite dans d'autres
continents que le nôtre c'est pourquoi
nous devons accélérer dans le réarmement
académique scientifique technologique
industrielle et agricole déjà largement
engagé grâce aux réformes conduites
depuis 6 ans grâce au plan de relance
puis au programme France 2030 là encore
c'est un choix
d'indépendance ne plus compter sur les
autres puissances pour écrire notre
histoire produire l'intelligence dans
nos universités notre énergie dans nos
centrales nucléaires et nos
installations de renouvelables notre
alimentation dans nos fermes nos biens
de consommation décarbonés dans nos
usines en français et en européen et
c'est
possible nous avons déjà beaucoup fait
et nous ferons beaucoup plus d'abord
nous poursuivrons les investissements
commencés les réformes
engagées mais je souhaite que nous
puissions accélérer car le monde est en
train d'accélérer regardez la Chine ou
les États-Unis d'Amérique sur ces
technologies ils vont beaucoup plus vite
que nous européens et français
pour cela nous mettrons fin aux normes
inutiles il y a encore trop de
complexité qui décourage les
entrepreneurs les industriels les
commerçants les agriculteurs les
artisans les maires ceux qui font ces
complexités bien souvent protègent des
rentes des statuts des situations
établies et nous ne pouvons plus nous le
permettre c'est pourquoi je demande au
gouvernement de supprimer des normes
réduire des délais faciliter encore les
embauches augmenter tous les seuils de
déclenchement d'obligations
c'est au fond la France du bon sens
plutôt que la France des tracas vieille
ancien diront certains je crois
effectivement qu'en la matière nous
avons eu trop de tabou c'est pourquoi je
demande au gouvernement de porter un
acte de d'une loi pour la croissance
l'activité les opportunités économiques
pour permettre de libérer davantage
encore ceux qui font qui Innov qui ose
qui
travaill produire plus innover
davantageer plus vite ceci et cette
indépendance par le travail et la
production nous pourrons le faire aussi
parce que plus de Français travailleront
c'est le sens d'ailleurs de beaucoup de
réformes conduites l'année dernière même
quand elles étaient
impopulaires mais nous le savons tous
notre pays encore aujourd'hui manque de
travailleurs dans les fermes dans nos
restaurants chez nos artisans pour aider
les personnes âgées ou les personnes
handicapées chez eux c'est une
réalité et il risque de manquer de main
de travailleurs dans les métiers que
nous sommes en train de créer du
nucléaire jusqu'au numérique et à
beaucoup
d'autres pour mettre fin à cette
anomalie nous devons former davantage
selon les besoins de la nation nous
avons commencé ce travail avec la
réforme du lycée professionnel de de nos
universités cet effort nous l'accélérons
cette année et jusqu'à la rentrée
prochaine le gouvernement incitera aussi
à la création et la reprise d'un emploi
avec dès le printemps prochain un acte 2
de la réforme du marché du travail lancé
en 2017 c'està-dire des règles plus
sévères quand des offres d'emploi sont
refusé et un meilleur accompagnement de
nos
chôeurs la formation mais aussi
l'accompagnement à l'emploi sur des
choses très concrètes comme le logement
les transports ceci pour atteindre le
plein
emploi la France sera plus forte si elle
retrouve son indépendance financière
nous avons beaucoup dépensé pendant la
crise covid nous savons tous et j'assume
ces dépenses parce qu'elles ont surtout
protég nos capacités de production une
reprise très rapide et les chiffres sont
là pour le montrer mais retrouver notre
indépendance financière c'est d'abord et
avant tout créer plus de
richesse donner un chiffre très simple
si la France avait le taux d'activité le
taux d'emploi de l'Allemagne nous
n'aurions pas de problème de finances
publi et donc le cœur de la bataille
budgétaire c'est une bataille pour
l'activité et la création d'emploi et de
richesse et à côté de ça le gouvernement
aura aussi à bâtir une ambitieuse revue
des dépenses pendant ce semestre une
vraie réforme de l'État pour dégager
aussi de l'efficacité dans nos dépenses
publiques la France sera plus forte car
elle dépendra dépendra encore moins de
l'étranger pour son énergie grâce à
davantage de nucléaire et d'énergie
renouvelable le programme que nous
allons accélérer j'y reviendrai au mois
de juin et sera armé face aux aléas du
changement climatique nos compatriotes à
la Réunion dans le pas decalis mais il y
a quelques mois en Bretagne en Normandie
l'ont encore vécu on sait bien que nous
devons réduire nos fragilités face aux
tempêtes aux incendies
aussi aux canicules et aux sécheresses
et ceci avec un plan d'adaptation et de
résilience sur nos territoires bâti avec
nos mères nos élus locaux en métropole
comme dans nos autres m notre France
sera aussi plus forte par la relance de
sa
natalité nous étions jusqu'à récemment
un pays dont c'était la force sans doute
la singularité en Europe quand on se
comparait aux voisins et c'est moins
vrai depuis quelques années alors il y a
derrière cela des angoisses qui vont
avec la société peut-être des pris jadis
sur certains sujets financiers il
appartiendra au gouvernement de
poursuivre ce travail mais je voudrais
insister sur deux points pour essayer
d'améliorer les choses après
l'allongement du congé paternité je
crois profondément que la mise en place
d'un nouveau congé de
naissance sera un élément utile dans une
une telle stratégie congé de naissance
qui viendra remplacer le congé parental
actuel d'abord il sera mieux rémunéré il
permettra aux deux parents d'être auprès
de leur enfant pendant 6 mois s'il le
souhaite mais surtout il sera plus court
que le congé parental actuel qui peut
parfois aller jusqu'à 3 ans et qui
éloigne beaucoup de femmes du marché du
travail mais qui aussi crée beaucoup
d'angoisse parce qu'il est extrêmement
peu et mal rémunéré et donc crée des
situations parfois
impossible la natalité baisse aussi
parce que l'infertilité progresse et je
parle là d'une forme de tabou du siècle
mais les meurs se
changent on fait les enfants de plus en
plus tard
l'infertilité masculine comme féminine a
beaucoup progressé ces dernières années
et fait souffrir beaucoup de couples un
grand plan de lutte contre ce fléo sera
engagé pour permettre justement ce
réarmement démographique enfin la France
sera plus forte parce que l'Europe sera
plus puissante je n'ai jamais opposé ces
deux notions je les défends même comme
des
complémentarités nous avons beaucoup
fait ces dernières années pour une
Europe de la santé une Europe de la
défense une Europe des technologies et
des grands programmes avec des vrais
résultats et on pourra revenir si vous
le souhaitez nous devons encore aller
plus loin sur ce sujet Les élections
européennes seront un rendez-vous et un
moment de vérité mais je crois
profondément que dans ce dérèglement que
j'aiévoqué une Europe plus puissante
plus unie plus souveraine est un élément
de réponse indispensable pour notre
pays la France sera plus
forte grâce à ses objectifs et
quelquesunes des actions que je viens
ici d'esquisser et c'est grâce à cela
qu'elle pourra aussi être plus
juste la première des
injustices je l'ai plusieurs reprises
évoqué c'est et cela reste
malheureusement celle du déterminisme
social et
familial nous n'avons pas les mêmes
chances et je dois reconnaître avec
honnêteté qu'après 6 ans et demi à
l'endroit où les Français m'ont mis nous
avons amélioré des choses mais nous ne
les avons pas radicalement changé
c'est-à-dire que l'avenir des enants ENF
de la République reste encore par trop
déterminé par le nom de famille
l'endroit où l'on est né le milieu
auquel on appartient c'est la pire des
injustices l'inégalité de départ la
promesse républicaine c'est celle de
l'égalité des chances et au fond je veux
qu'on mette fin à cette France du ceci
n'est pas pour moi ou ceci n'est pas
pour toi de ces enfants qui continuent à
se dire que parce qu'ils viennent de de
ce quartier qu'ils ont ce nom l'accès à
telle formation ou tel diplôme l'accès à
la culture ne leur est pas du n'est pas
un droit pour eux ça existe c'est une
réalité et aussi longtemps que ça existe
ça vient éroder l'adhésion à la promesse
républicaine et tout ce que je viens de
vous dire sur l'ordre ne sera pas
possible tout ce que je viens de vous
dire sur la force sera aussi affaibli
vous retrouverez une forme d'en même
temps qui est familier mais qui n'est
pas une faiblesse qui est une double
radicalité qui n'est pas une ambiguïé
qui est une double ambition car et c'est
vrai depuis le début de notre 3e
république l'ordre va avec le progrès
l'autorité va avec l'émancipation
indissociable et donc oui la réponse à
ça c'est l'école l'école l'école là
aussi continuer le travail commencer
avec encore plus de
force près des enfants les plus en
difficulté systématiser les devoirs fait
au collège en particulier dans les
endroits les plus en difficulté c'est
indispensable travailler sur les
vacances et le temps scolaire Premier
ministre nager ministre de l'éducation
nationale avait commencé ce travail pour
décaler les examens parce que les
vacances longues sont un élément
d'injustice sociale et commencer aussi
dès la 5e l'accompagnement à
l'orientation qui est un élément
absolument décisif d'une plus grande
égalité et c'est tout ce que nous allons
conduire au collège au lycée et au
premier cycle universitaire avec les
ministres qui sont maintenant en charge
de ces sujets c'est aussi ce travail que
je veux continuer par un meilleur accès
à la culture et qui sera au cœur du
mandat de la ministre faire en sorte que
d'où conv viennent des quartiers
populaires urbains à notre rur on puisse
avoir accès à la
culture dès l'école et
après la deuxième injustice
fondamentale c'est que l'effort et le
mérite ne sont pas suffisamment reconnus
je crois dans cette France en effet du
travail et du mérite et si nous avons
déjà beaucoup fait pour que le travail P
mieux que l'inactivité on pourra y
revenir on a substantiellement fait et
nous sommes sans doute le pays d'Europe
où le pouvoir d'achat des travailleurs
et des travailleurs les plus modestes a
le plus progresser ces 5 dernières
années malgré l'inflation ça n'est pas
assez et au fond il y a ce que
j'appelleraai une France de l'anglemort
c'est tous nos compatriotes qui gagnent
déjà trop pour être aidé et pas assez
pour bien vivre c'est la France
populaire la France des classes moyennes
la France qui dit quand vous proposez
quelque chose c'est jamais pour
moi et pourtant c'est celle qui tient le
pays et donc au cœur du mandat du
gouvernement je souhaite qu'il y ait
justement
un travail ardent pour aller plus
loin pour reconnaître cela pour donner
plus de dynamique au carrière pour
permettre de mieux gagner sa vie par le
travail avec l'adaptation de nos
dispositifs fiscaux et sociaux mais
aussi avec des négociations dans
certaines branches pour que la dynamique
salariale soit au rendez-vous des
efforts il en va de même pour nos
fonctionnaires pour lesquels le
principal critère d'avancement et de
rémunération
devra être à côté de l'ancienneté
également le
mérite tout cas bien davantage
qu'aujourd'hui ce sera au cœur d'une
réforme qui va commencer dans les
prochaines semaines une France plus
juste c'est aussi une France qui sait
accompagné les transitions qui sont à
l'œuvre je le disais beaucoup des
changements qui sont en cours et on le
voit partout en Europe nourrisent de
l'inquiétude parce que si nous ny
prenons pas garde et la France l'a vécu
avec la crise que nous avons traversé
ensemble des gilets jaunes ces
transitions sont injustes elle frappe
encore
plus ceux qui sont dans la difficulté
ceux qui ont déjà à peine les moyens de
vivre de leur travail qui sont souvent
dans les logements les moins bien isolés
qui par nécessité sont obligés de rouler
dans des véhicules individuels qui sont
parfois encore les plus polluants s'agit
pas de symatiser France au contraire il
faut l'aider à la transition c'est ça
l'écologie à la française c'est une
écologie de justice et de souveraineté
et donc nous allons accroître dans les
prochains mois d'abord l'accompagnement
de nos agriculteurs pour les aider
justement à améliorer le pratique jamais
en laissant sans solution simplification
accompagnement et investissement
accompagner les Français en investissant
dans les transports en commun en les
aidant par le bonus écologique mais
aussi le leasing social pour la voiture
à 100 € à changer de véhicule et les
accompagner encore davantage de manière
plus simple pour
rénover le logement faire de la
transition écologque
juste la France plus juste enfin c'est
celle qui accompagne chacun grâce à nos
services publics en la matière beaucoup
de Français ont le sentiment légitime de
ne pas en avoir pour leur argent si je
puis dire pas de médecins disponiblebl
lorsqu'ils sont malades pas d'agents au
bout du fil quand ils font une démarche
des délais trop longs dans les papiers
d'identité et parfois même le sentiment
que ça fonctionne surtout pour ceux qui
ont despasse
droit lors de mon premier quinena nous
avons beaucoup fait sur ce sujet on a
réinvesti on a déconcentré beaucoup de
services publics on a recréé des
sous-préfectures c'était pas arrivé
depuis des décennies on a rouvert des
trésoreries sur le terrain on a rouvert
des brigades de gendarmerie on vient
encore d'enclencher un mouvement pour en
rouvrir
200 j'avais fait une promesse ici même à
la fin du grand débat que dans chaque
canton il y ait une maison France
service promesse tenue même dépassé 2700
maisons France service existe
aujourd'hui partout sur le terrain ce
qui qui place chacun d'entre nous à 20
minutes de l'une d'entre elles qu'on
habite un quartier populaire en
ruralité dans les grandes villes mais
soyons lucide nous n'y sommes pas encore
parce qu'on est encore prisonnier sans
doute de trop de tabou de prê à penser
je demande donc au gouvernement de
sortir si je puis dire des codes et des
cases d'envisager des solutions plus
radicales pour mettre fin à ce qui
alimente ce sentiment de déclassement
solution radicale pour mettre fin au
scandal des déserts médicaux en Simp
les règles venues d'en haut en
permettant d'adapter ces règles au
terrain pour permettre des coordinations
plus simples en dégageant du temps au
médecin pour mieux travailler entre
médecine de ville et hôpital avec aussi
ce qu'on appelle les professions
paramédicales sera au cœur du mandat de
la ministre afin que chaque médecin mais
aussi par puisse voir plus de patients
mais aussi en assumant sur le terrain de
régulariser nombre de médecins étrangers
qui tiennent par fois à bout de bras nos
services de soins et que nous laissons
dans une précarité administrative qui
est complètement
inefficace solution radical en taillant
enfin dans le vif des dépenses inutiles
des doublons administratifs du
millefeuille comme on l'appelle pour
permettre un service plus efficace
auprès des Français et des règles
beaucoup plus simples et rapides par les
simplifications que j'évoqué tout à
l'heure au fond nous devons avoir la
force l'énergie dans ce moment
d'envisager ce que nous n'envisageions
plus d'oser ce que nous n'osions même
plus penser de retrouver de
l'audace vous l'avez compris il s'agit
de faire preuve d'efficacité de briser
même certains tabout de ne pas avoir
peur de soulever certains mécontentement
au service des Français c'est bien sûr
au gouvernement d'insuffler ce mouvement
et je sais qu'il ne ménagera ni son
énergie ni son talent mais chacun doit
prendre sa
part l'état bien sûr doit être là pour
accompagner pour impulser jamais pour
entraver mais la la force de mouvement
réside aussi en chacun de nous nous
avons besoin d'une France de
l'engagement et de la mobilisation
civile parce qu'être français c'est
d'avoir c'est avant tout avoir des
droits et des devoirs c'est porter une
certaine idée de notre nation de son
histoire de son ambition c'est pourquoi
je compte
aussi sur l'engagement et la
mobilisation de nos compatriotes en
exagone et dans nos outremer pour
prendre leur part de cette mobilisation
afin de rendre notre pays plus fort et
plus juste et de relever les défis du
temps vous l'avez compris je pense que
beaucoup de choses sont possibles et je
ne cède pas à l'esprit de
résignation que je vois quand même à
l'œuvre il y a beaucoup de choses qui
nous inquiète légitimement parce que
beaucoup de changements sont en cours
parce qu'on a vécu tant de
crisees mais je crois que si nous savons
travailler ardemment avec beaucoup de
bon sens d'efficacité sans doute moins
de lois mais plus d'actions concrètes
avec une détermination sans
faille nous aurons des résultats au
service à la fois du quotidien des
Français mais aussi pour préparer
l'avenir de la nation et cette France
plus forte et plus juste de l'audace de
l'efficacité de l'action c'est ce qui
est demandé à ce nouveau gouvernement ce
à quoi je m'emploirai maintenant je vais
répondre à toutes vos
questions bonsoir monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs chers
collègues jeanudau au nom de de
l'association la PR présidentiel on
voulait juste rappeler quelques petits
points pour les personnes qui nous
regardent nous écoutent rappelez que les
journalistes c'est une conférence de
presse les journalistes sont libres de
poser toutes les questions qu'il
souhaite au chef de l'État aucune
question n'est jamais soumise en amont
au chef de l'État c'est toujours mieux
de le dire toutefois dans un souci de
lisibilité l'Élisée aimerait que cette
conférence de presse soit divisée en
trois parties d'abord un premier
chapitre national avec les réformes les
annonces qui viennent d'être formulé
puis une partie axée sur l'actualité
plus strictement politique et enfin les
questions internationales vous le voyez
tous on est très nombreux ce soir afin
que la parole puisse circuler auprès
d'un maximum de journalistes
l'Association de la presse
présidentielle vous recommande de vous
encourage à ne formuler qu'une seule
question par prise de parole question
courte s'il vous plaît et de la même
manière monsieur le Président nous
savons pouvoir compter sur la concision
de vos
réponses RZ pas quand
même bonsoir monsieur le Président
Bastien pour TF1 et LCI vous avez parlé
à l'instant des classes moyennes et
populaires et de leur pouvoir d'achat
est-ce que vous pouvez nous préciser
comment vous comptez vous y prendre
comment vous demandez à votre
gouvernement de s'y prendre pour
augmenter leur pouvoir d'achat est-ce
que vous envisagez par exemple
d'augmenter le SMIC et quand allez-vous
rendre effective votre promesse de
baisser de 2 milliards d'euros les
impôts des Français et puis est-ce que
tout cela aura du sens si vous laissez
les Français payz plus cher leur
électricité comme c'est prévu le mois
prochain je vous
remercie c'est un tout le pouvoir
d'achat c'est au fond la rend compte
d'un coût de la vie et de la
rémunération d'un
travail la France a beaucoup protégé
face à l'inflation ces dernières années
l'inflation énergétique nous avons
dépensé 100 milliards d'euros pour
protéger nos compatriotes donc au moment
où les prix reviennne dans la norme il
est légitime qu'il y ait en effet des
augmentations le gouvernement y
reviendra parce que soyons clair quand
l'État protège c'est le contribuable
d'aujourd'hui ou de demain qui paye par
que le consommateur ne paye pas
l'inflation c'est un impôt extérieur
alors oui il y aura cette normalisation
mais je le disais nous avons beaucoup
protégé maintenant pour aider les
classes populaires et les classes moyenn
d'abord nous allons tout faire pour
justement retrouver la maîtrise de nos
prix Les prix de l'alimentation vont
revenir dans des zones qui sont beaucoup
plus raisonnables on vient de le voir
avec la fin des négociations
commerciales qu'on avait anticipé il
faut qu'il y a un prix juste pour que
nos agriculteurs et nos PME puissent
vivre de leur travail mais on sera très
loin de l'inflation qu'on a connu
l'année dernière même l'année d'avant et
nous allons être vigilants dans les
prochains mois pour tenir des prix qui
permettent à chacun de vivre et qui aide
justement à ce que on maîtrise
véritablement les prix de l'alimentaire
sur l'énergie on rentre dans une période
de normalisation et une partie des prix
de l'énergie servent à financer notre
programme nucléaire et notre
renouvelable mais on a retrouvé de la
maîtrise et le gouvernement a apporté un
texte qui grâce à ce qu'on a négocié en
Europe va nous permettre de ne plus
avoir la volatil on avait connu pendant
la crise lié à la guerre en Ukraine
c'estàdire qu'on retrouve une énergie
qu'on paye à nos cû de production et
grâce au nucléaire et à ce que nous
sommes en train de développer ça veut
dire une énergie dont on tient mieux les
coûts et avec beaucoup plus de
visibilité dès cette année le
gouvernement aura à tout faire pour que
le travail paye mieux alors on a là
aussi beaucoup
fait quand je regarde ces 5 dernières
années le sic a augmenté de 20 %
20% les sm ont gagné pouvoir d'achat un
travailleur qui est au à temps complet a
gagné depuis depuis 2017
9 % de pouvoir d'achat et aucun pays
européen vous est arrivé parce qu'en
plus de ça on a mis les 100 € de prime
d'activité promesse de sortie du grand
débat parce qu'on a baissé l'impôt sur
le revenu de 5 milliards concentré sur
les classes moyennes parce qu'on a
supprimer la taxe d'habitation faut
continuer ce travail sur plusieurs axes
d'abord c'est tout un chantier qu'on a
lancé pour que notre fiscalité nos
cotisation sociale permettent de mieux
accompagner d'abord ceux qui reviennent
au travail mais aussi les Français qui
sont au SMIC et un peu au-dessus du SMIC
parce que sinon on a une trappe à bas
salaire dans notre pays c'est ça l'un
des problèmes qu'on a la deuxième chose
pour que branche par branche on ait des
dynamiques salariales par un partage de
la valeur ajoutée de la valeur crée qui
soit beaucoup plus juste et fort là
aussi on a commencé à le faire on a 9
millions et demi de nos compatriotes qui
ont touché les fameuses primes et le
partage de la valeur ajoutée on va aller
plus loin et puis dès 2025 ça tout je
vous dis c'est sur 202 et il y aura des
mesures de court terme que le premier
ministre aura a annoncé donc sur la
rémunération du travail il y aura un
travail avec les branches qui continuent
de payer sous le SMIC pour qu'ell
réembauche davantage et qu'elles
attirent plus de travailleurs qu'elles
améliorent les conditions de travail et
qu'ell permettent d'avoir des dynamiques
salariales retrouvé et ça ça vaut pour
les métiers de la restauration les
métiers du soin beaucoup de métiers
d'ailleurs manuels est souvent difficile
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles il
continue à avoir du mal à recruté et on
aura entre autres dans notre trajectoire
financière 2 milliards de baisses
d'impôt sur nos compatriotes qui sont
dans ces catégories en 2025 et le
gouvernement reviendra sur le détail de
la mesure voilà les grands axes de la
stratégie bonsoir monsieur le Président
Guillaume darret pour France Télévision
vous venez de faire de nouvelles
annonces concernant notamment le secteur
de l'école vous évoquez la question de
l'éducation civique très concrètement
est-ce que vous êtes favorable par
exemple à ce que les élèves de primaire
apprennent obligatoirement la
Marseillaise comme chose pour s'unir
avec la nation est-ce que la
généralisation de l'uniforme c'est
vraiment la priorité est-ce que la
priorité c'est pas plutôt qu'il y ait un
enseignant en face de chaque élève ce à
quoi vous vous étiez engagé
personnellement il y a quelques mois on
l'a vu c'est pas encore le cas partout
et on l'a vu aussi ces derniers jours ça
continue de faire débat et polémique au
sein même de votre gouvernement on
reviendra sans doute dans le moment plus
politique sur ce sujet je l'imagine mais
il y a pas de polémique dans le
gouvernement sur le fait qu'il doit y
avoir un un enseignant devant chaque
élève je vous rassure tout se tient tout
se tient c'est-à-dire que on a un énorme
travail à faire avec les
familles j'ai commencé par là mais on a
en effet à l'école et c'est ce qu'on a
commencé depuis
2017 aller au bout de ce choc des
savoirs l'école primaire avec laquelle
vous avez commencé c'est là où on
apprend à compter à écrire à lire aussi
à se comporter c'est là où on apprend
des valeurs je suis totalement favorable
à ce qu'on apprenne la Marseillaise au
primaire totalement c'est même
indispensable parce que c'est ce qui
nous unit c'est le fruit de notre
histoire à ce qu' estit donc l'heure
sanctuarisée si je puis dire de d la 5e
d'instruction civique avec un programme
qui est redéfin et qui permet de bien
mieux connaître à la fois l'histoire de
notre nation notre république de nos
institutions et nos grands textes parce
que c'est ce qui nous unit c'est ce qui
nous permet d'être ensemble en société
ce qui fait que je l'avais dit je meen
souviens très bien à la fin du grand
débat c'est ce qui sépare c'est ce qui
différencie plutôt une nation d'une
société une société sont des individus
libres qui coopèrent qui s'organisent et
cetera nous sommes une société mais on
est plus que ça on a un supplément d'âme
on a une langue une histoire des choses
intemporelles qui nous lient et un
mystérieux projet commun qui fait que
face à l'adversité on se rassemble pour
affronter les événements c'est ça une
nation c'est a quelque chose de
spirituel qui nous dépasse et ça
s'apprend à travers cette histoire et
c'estes choses aussi symboliques il faut
retrouver aussi le sens du symbolique et
c'est pour ça que la Marseillaise on
fait partie j'y suis favorable la tenue
unique ça n'est pas innocent c'est pas
innocent et d'abord parce que ça a été
un débat de société pendant des semaines
tout le monde en a parlé les semaines
que disje des mois je peux pas vous dire
ça sert à rien non et moi j'aime bien la
méthode que le gouvernement a décider
d'employer qui est pragmatique ça fait
débat n'ayons pas des débats si je puis
dire
théoriques ne renvoyons pas dogme contre
dogme certitude contre certitude on
expériimente on évalue on est
transparent et on regarde c'est un débat
il y a 100 établissements qui sont
candidats on leur permet dès cette année
certains je crois vont le faire dès la
sortie des vacances là d'hiver il le
mettent en place tenu unique ou uniforme
pour l'expérimentation on va même
accompagner les familles ce sera pris en
charge par les collectivités locales et
l'État et on va mettre les meilleurs
experts ils vont évaluer qu'est-ce que
ça fait est-ce qu'on apprend mieux
est-ce que ça change rien est-ce que ça
crée des tensions est-ce que le débat
public sera éclairer c'est ça une
démocratie adulte et à l'Ô de ce qui
aura été évalué on dira ça marche ça
marche pas ça sert à rien et on décidera
de le généraliser ou pas je crois que
c'est la bonne manière d'avancer enfin
oui j'ai dit dès le début le choc des
savoirs c'est avoir des maîtres mieux
formés c'est pourquoi on va complètement
revoir tout cela moi je crois un système
en lien avec notre université mais où on
a au fond des compatriotes qui veulent
l'enseigner qui dès après le bacaluréat
puisse être formé au métier d'enseignant
je veux pas dire tout de suite qu'on va
revenir au vieux système de nos écoles
normales c'était pas si mauvais en tout
là où aujourd'hui au fond on demande des
chemins universitaires qui sont parfois
très divers mais on ne forme pas au
métier d'enseigner tout de suite donc on
va repenser la formation et dès ce
trimestre on aura des annonces fortes
avec refonde complète du système de
formation des maîtres on les rémunère
mieux avec le PACT enseignant et c'est
des il y a une une part de la
rémunération qui a augmenté pour tout le
monde qui est inconditionnelle et qui
est historique on l'avait pas vu depuis
les années 90 et une part qui est liée à
l'adhésion au pacte pour pouvoir faire
des tâches supplémentaires accompagner
les devoirs fait qui permettent de
lutter contre les injustices permettre
de mieux accompagner justement dans
l'orientation et permettre entre autres
d'adhérer au remplacement remplacement
dans notre code je le rappelle c'est
censé être une
obligation durant mon premier quinena on
s'est attaqué au remplacement long je
vous le dire parce que moi j'ai creusé
le sujet depuis 6 ans et demi on avait
nos fameux objets de la quotidienne à
des conseils des ministres réguliers les
ministres qui sont là et qui
m'accompagnent de long temps le savent
ont passer en revue ces objets et on a
des résultats formidable parce que on a
plus de 95
% des absences qui sont comblé tes
qu'elles étaient mesurées c'est les
absence de plus de 15 jours c'est tout
ce qu'on a suivi durant le premier
quinen on est à 95 % je crois en 2022
2023 c'est le taux de remplacement on a
même atteint certaines années davantage
c'est au-dessus de 15 jours d'absence
c'est ça qu' mesurer moi j'arrive en fin
de mon premier mandat je dis formidable
on a quand même un bon
résultat il y a 95 % des absences qui
sont comblés mais on arrive à mettre un
prof devant les élèves le ressenti sur
le terrain n'était pas le même pourquoi
parce qu'on ne faisait pas remonter au
National les absences de court terme on
les mesurait même pas donc on a ouvert
le capot et on est allé regarder le
remplacement de court terme et on s'est
aperçu qu'il y avait une dizaine de
millions d'heures chaque année
é
perd vous n'z pas un professeur devant
un élève et c'est ça qui est
insupportable pour les parents on a on a
réussi à répondre au problème d'absence
long des professeurs et on est en train
de s'attaquers ABS de courte durée
professurs par avait une formation on a
complètement le système et donc là on
est enain de s'organiser on a commencer
pour que les formations lesett tout à
fait légitime se f pas sur leur temps
d'école et le temps de travail d'un d'un
professeur c'est pas que le temps devant
les élèves il a du temps de préparation
du temps de correction des copies et il
travaille beaucoup nos enseignants mais
on peut s'organiser pour que les
formations auxquelles ils ont droit et
que nous encourageons se fassent pas sur
le temps devant les élèves deuxième
chose on utilisait si je puis dire on
gaspillait du temps de professeur pour
surveiller les examens on réorganise ça
et puis troisème chose on doit mieux
organiser au sein des établissements le
remplacement de courte durée vous avez
un professeur qui est malade tel jour
qui a une qui peut pas être là bah il
faut encourager les autres enseignants
qui peuvent être disponibles à reprendre
cette heure et à la faire et elle sera
payée en heure supplémentaire ou dans le
cadre du Pacte je rentre dans les
détails ça paraît du bon sens mais c'est
pas ce qui étaé fait donc c'est une
réorganisation complète le pacte permet
de le faire c'est à ça qu'on s'attaque
on n'est pas 100 % de réussite bien loin
on est passé de 5 % à 15 % à peu près
donc vous voyez qu'on est loin du
résultat c'est pour ça qu'on a raison de
s'y attaquer avec beaucoup de force
c'est de la
réorganisation nos profess sont nos
meilleurs alliés sur ce sujet là et
c'est aussi pour ça qu'on a décidé de
mieux les payer quand ils adhéraient à
cela par les heures supplémentaires et
par le pacte voilà où on en est
exactement et donc je peux vous dire que
avec le Premier ministre la ministre de
l'Éducation nationale la jeunesse et des
sports on va continuer de s'attaquer
avec force à ce sujet du remplacement
pour que tous les élèves et bien un
professeur devant chaque heure de cours
qui est
prévu monsieur le Président ici bonsoir
gral vous avez annoncé une grande loi
sur l'économie est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire de façon plus précise ce qu'il
y aura à l'intérieur et concernant le
pouvoir d'achat est-ce que vous allez
contraindre les entreprises à mieux
rémunérer les les salariés ou est-ce que
vous allez vous souhaitez rester plutôt
dans le domaine de l'incitation merci
sur le deuxème point d'abord il y a ce
que nous pouvons faire nous qui est à
notre main on a du fiscal et du social
et ça il peut y avoir des moments de
dialogue mais c'est des des choix qui
sont à la main du gouvernement la
deuxème chose sur les salaires je suis
plutôt pour que ça continue à se faire
au niveau de l'entreprise c'est comme ça
que ça marche mais nous allons
encourager les branches euh où il y a
encore des difficultés de rémunération à
accélérer les négociations pour qu'elles
puissent se conformer aux dynamiques des
derniers mois et surtout à donner plus
de dynamique au dialogue social au
niveau de l'entreprise et puis on va
continuer d'avancer dans ce qu'on a
beaucoup fait durant le premier mandat
qui est de de faciliter d'encourager de
simplifier le partage de la valeur
ajoutée de la loi pacte aux primes qu'on
a mis en place qui ont bénéficié après
100 millions de travailleurs
jusqu'à l'accord national
interprofessionnel de valeur de partage
de la valeur ajoutée qui a été transposé
on a énormément simplifié le paysage là
faut encore encouragé de le faire je ne
suis pas pour que on le fasse de manière
réglementaire législative c'est par le
dialogue social sil a besoin de
simplifier des instruments on le fera
parce que
sinon on met à risque si je puis dire
notre compétitivité et surtout on n'est
pas dans une économie réglementée pour
ce qui est d'un temps de de la
simplification c'est le premier ministre
qui reviendra dans son discours de
politique générale et c'est au ministre
de construire cela mais on a beaucoup de
choses très simples à faire très
pratique si
l'administration needemand n'avait pas
le droit de demander des documents
qu'elle a demandé dans les 12 derniers
mois ou les deux dernières années on
changerait la vie de beaucoup de
gens et pour les entreprises et pour les
particuliers si la situation de ces
derniers n'avait pas changé si on
bougeait les seuils sur beaucoup de
seuils qu'on a réglementaire ou légau
sur beaucoup de sujets en les passant à
une étape supplémentaire on
simplifierait la vie de beaucoup de gens
si on réduisait drastiquement les délais
d'instruction ou autre il y a des tas de
choses très concrètes qu'on peut faire
c'est très compliqué de simplifier j'en
parle d'expérience mais ce que je dis
c'est qu'il faut remettre de l'audace et
de l'énergie dans le système maintenant
et c'est pas impossible de le faire et
j'ai un très bon exemple pour ça c'est
les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques on nous dit ce qui est
vrai on y reviendra peut-être dans vos
questions le logement est en crise c'est
vrai et une des partie des cris du
logement c'est un un aspect conjoncturel
la montée des taux qui fait que le
logement reposait entre autres dans son
économie sur des taux bas pendant très
longtemps ça monte ça fait qu'il y a une
contrainte de crédit beaucoup de gens
n'accèdent plus au logement les
promoteurs son sont pression mais on a
un système qui est un Maqui c'est très
compliqué le foncier est trop cher les
délais sont trop longs tout ça crée du
coût pour nous tous quand on veut
acquérir un logement ou quand on loue
dans un des endroits où c'est le plus
compliqué le plus long de construire en
France la région parisienne parce qu'il
a les Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
on a pris une loi urgence il y a 5 ans
et
demi les logements vont sortir de terre
pour les Jeux Olympiques la loi on l'a
prise fin 2017 début 2018 on a construit
avec plusieurs communes de SC saint un
énorme programme de bureaux et de
logement il verra le jour à l'heure pour
les Jeux Olympiques et
paralympique c'est possible et donc on
va faire aussi des grosses
simplifications des grosses opérations
d'intérêt national on va réduire les
choses simplement faut réduire les
délais faut contraindre les procédures
faut éviter les recours multiples à tous
les étages qui ont qui ont toujours été
fait pour des bonnes raisons qui sont
sédimenté avec le temps mais qui fait
que on est tous confronté à ça dans not
viis
quotidiennes très souvent ça paraît
impossible de faire et au fond les gens
se demandent plus est-ce que qu'est-ce
qui est pas interdit plutôt que au fond
est-ce que je peux vraiment faire et
avancer faut y aller voilà c'est tous
ces axesl les seuils les délais les
simplification les procédures uniques et
ça va toucher nos agriculteurs nos
artisans nos commerçants nos
entrepreneurs
et nos
élus bonsoir monsieur le Président vous
avez évoqué dans le propos liminaire le
problème des déserts médicaux et vous
avez insisté sur tout ce que vous avez
mis en place pour arriver à à y mettre
fin euh mais il y a une chose dont vous
avez pas parlé vous n'avez pas dit si
vous étiez favorable ou pas euh à des
contraintes pour l'installation des
médecins dans les les déserts médicaux
vous qui voulez sortir des codes et des
cases est-ce que que c'est quelque chose
que vous allez mettre en place alors le
problème il est simple m non je le je
redonne le cadre pour nous tous on a
aujourd'hui un peu moins de 100000
médecins
généralistes on en a perdu 6000 en 10
ans c'est ça la réalité et
euh malgré le fait qu'en 2018 j'ai
décidé de rouvrir le numérus closus et
donc de créer plus de placees on met 10
ans à former des médecins et on a
environ 25 à 30 % de nos médecins
généralistes qui ont plus de 60 ans
c'est pas compliqué on a un problème et
à côté de ça on a une population qui
vieillit qui a de plus en plus de
maladies chroniqu c'est ça le problème
il est assez simple il aurait dû être
anticipé il y a 15 20 30 ans donc on
doit créer plus de postes et donc et ça
ça va se faire à travers le temps mais
là pour nous les 5 à 7 ans qui viennent
le seul moyen c'est d'organiser
différemment les choses alors est-ce que
la contrainte c'est la bonne
solution ma réponse est NON je vous
parle je suis d'une famille de médecins
je suis le seul mauvais élève de ma
famille qui n''est pas fait
ça quel est le problème aussi qu'on a
pourquoi on n' pas assez d'ofre de soin
parce que les médecins qui font plus de
10 ans d'études ils vous disent à juste
titre quand ils finissent vous me posez
des contraintes pour la convention pas
la convention en fait j'ai contribué à
l'effort national j'ai fait tourner
l'hôpital comme externe et comme interne
ce qui est vrai dans notre système vous
allez pas me dire que je vais
m'installer là haut là parce que
qu'est-ce qui va se passer je vous le
signe ils quitteront et là des problèmes
qu'on a d'ailleurs aujourd'hui c'est
qu'à cause les habitudes ont changé là
aussi les meurs se changent beaucoup des
médecins qu'on a formé arrêtent leur
activité de médecine ils vont vers le
secteur privé c'estàd dans l'entreprise
dans des laboratoires ils changent
d'activité quand ils sont à deux parfois
il y en a un qui se met en activité
partielle ils veulent pas travailler
comme leurs
aînés ve plus être le médecin de
campagne ou le médecin de ville qui
prend des rendez-vous à longueur de
temps qui est réveillable la nuit et
donc il faut qu'on qu'on s'adapte au
changement d'époque et donc c'est une
solution qui paraît plus
simple mais je n'y crois pas compte tenu
de aujourd'hui la manière dont les
étudiants sont formés et dont
l'équilibre même de notre hôpital tient
si on voulait faire ça faurait
complètement changer le système des
externes des internes et autres par
contre je suis sûr d'une chose on a une
révolution de l'organisation à faire je
crois que ça c'est beaucoup plus
audacieux que de les obliger aller là
aussi où je crois peu l'obligation
d'installation c'est que il y a
quasiment peu d'endroits où il y a pas
de désert
médical et quand on dit quand on pense
qu'il y a des Nirvanas surdotés c'est
vrai dans certaines zones très urbaines
très riches où les liotropisme joue dans
certaines spécialités
médecin généraliste c'est plus tellement
vrai donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
faut libérer du temps de médecin un
aller vers une rémunération plus
intelligente sans doute en fait au
patient plutôt qu'à l'acte ce qui
permettra de mieux intégrer la
prévention aujourd'hui vous êtes pas
incité à faire de la prévention du bon
travail de prévention vous êtes plutôt
incité à faire le maximum d' de faire
beaucoup plus travailler ensemble la
ville et l'hôpital comme on l'a fait en
période covid TR déléguer des actes on
l'a fait pendant le covid
on a fait ensemble des petites
révolutions d'abord on a développé la
téléconsultation ça permet deérer du
temps de médecin et d'aller face au D
médicau permettre que des vaccinations
des renouvellement d'ordonnan dans le
cadre réseau de soin organis soit fait
par votre pharmacienaenne de référence
par l'infirmier ou l'infirmière de
déléguer des actes à des paramédicaux
qui permettent de libérer du temps et de
prendre plus de patien permettre aussi
de mieux organiser les choses dans ces
maisons de santé qui entre
professionnels médicaux paramédicaux
permet de mieux organiser le travail et
puis on a un vrai problème sur ce qu'on
appelle le soin non programmé c'est ce
qui fait que nos urgences sont engorgées
là faut mieux organiser ce ces ces accès
aux soins là-dessus qu'est-ce qu'on a
fait on a déjà doublé en 6 ans le nombre
de maisons de santé on a près de 70 % de
notre population qui est couverte par la
régulation téléphonique médical et la
réponse aux aides d'urgence ces fameux
SAS donc on a beaucoup progressé faut
aller au bout de çael faut aller au bout
de ce qu'on a commencé à faire on y est
quasiment on est à 95 % mais que les
patients en affection longue durée les
plus âgés et un médecin de référence et
il faut démultiplier cette logique de
terrain et c'est ça ce qu'onit la
solution elle est sur le
terrain je l'ai vu avec plusieurs
d'entre vous der moi dans un même
département quand vous avez des gens qui
savent coopérer entre l'hôpital la ville
les paramédicaux qui font en fait ce que
je suis en train de dire ou qui l'ont
déjà développé il y a pas de désert là
où vous avez des mes qui se parlent pas
où il y a pas eu assez de on n pas assez
prévu le changement vous avez un désert
qui s'est créé et donc c'est pourquoi je
crois à ces conseils de la refondation
territorialisée en santé on a dans notre
pays 1200 bassins de vie pas très joli
comme terme-ce que c'est un bassin de
vie ça correspond à peu près à nos
intercommunalités mais c'est une réalité
physique sensible dans chacun d'entrex
feuille de route de santé qui va inclure
l'hôpital la clinique ville le
paramédical et cetera ça on va créer des
postes on les aide on va les accompagner
avec plus d'assistants médicaux on a
déjà déployé 4600 donc voyez c'est une
stratégie d'ensemble au plus près du
terrain et au fond la philosophie de
cette stratégie c'est quoi on doit
libérer du temps médical en enlevant du
temps administratif et du temps médical
mal utilisé pour nos médecins et on doit
faire mieux travailler tout le monde
ensemble et puis on doit si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi débureaucratiser notre
santé
parce que très longtemps pour mieux
maîtriser les coûts on a créé des
administrations fortes au National et en
région il y a des gens qui font un
travail formidable mais il faut plutôt
qu'on mette ses services en soutien des
équipes de santé sur ces bassins de vie
pour les accompagner à trouver des
solutions c'est faisable je crois plus à
ça qu'à la contrainte après là aussi si
dans certains endroits on veut
expérimenter ou autre je veux bien mais
on a besoin que nos soignants soi
surtout mobilisés qu'ils y trouvent leur
compte et donc cette stratégie elle
marche que si on engage les médecins les
infirmiers euh les aides médicaux les
auxiliaires de vie parce que c'est le
médical médicosocial les kinés les les
pharmaciens et euh et les aid soignants
et j'en passe
voilà monsieur le Président de la
République Neila l trousse BFM TV vous
venez d'évoquer euh les urgences
engorgées est-ce que cont tenu des
difficultés qu'a connu l'hôpital encore
cet hiver vous renoncez à votre promesse
de désengorger les urgences d'ici la fin
de l'année et un secteur aussi
prioritaire que la santé peut-il se
permettre 5 ministres en 2 ans alors
d'abord je pense que surtout un secteur
comme la
santé exiger un investissement
historique ce que nous avons fait avec
le segure historique jamais dans notre
histoire on a autant réinvesti sur les
salaires dire nos soignants à l'hôpital
ont eu une augmentation de salaire
mensuel de 200 à 480 € par mois jamais
ça n'avait existé dans notre histoire
par mois et c'est du salaire pas des
primes qui sont pas pris en compte et un
peu plus de 19 milliards d'euros
d'investissement pour rénover nos
hôpitaux bon donc c'est ça dont av
besoin de notre santé on l'a fait
maintenant faut le déployer c'est un
énorme travail d'organisation qui est
mené un peu partout en France avec une
mobilisation de nos équipes hospitalière
administrative et médicale exemplaire et
je les en remercie donc oui on va tenir
l'objectif bien sûr et on tient comment
avec la stratégie que je viens d'évoquer
pour votre collègue on a déjà développé
pour 10 % de notre population ce qu'on
appelle les SAS c'est-à-dire ce
dispositif pour le soin non programmer
c'était zéro il y a 2 ans il y a 3 ans
cétait zéro c'estàd qu'en fait il y a 3
ans comme on avait mis
fin c'était il y a une quinzaine
d'années à l'obligation de garde vous
vous souvenez de ce système qui était
quand même pas mal où il y avait
l'obligation pour les médecins sur un
territoire de s'organiser la nuit et les
weekend on a mis fin à ça au début des
années 2000 bah le système c'était plus
organisé et c'est ça qui a renvoyé toute
la pression à l'hôpital c'est le fait
que vous n'aviez plus de réponse pour ce
qu'on appelle le soin non programmé
c'estd au fond vous aviez le choix entre
prendre rendez-vous chez votre médecin
si vous en aviez un ou aller directement
aux urgences bah là on a recréé un
système en coopérant avec justement les
médecins sur le
terrain qui permet d'avoir un numéro de
téléphonie médical qui permet une
demande d'aide médicale d'urgence pour
les soins B programmés et qui permet
d'organiser le système entre les
infirmiers les infirmières et les
médecins sur un même territoire mais en
les rémunérant mieux et en leur donnant
un accompagnement administratif on en
est à 70 % on sera on va essayer d'aller
à 100 % dè C durant cette année
2024 si on fait ça on désengorge
beaucoup les urgences parce qu'on a une
vraie réponse et puis à côté de ça il
faut qu'on continue de mieux
responsabiliser C et ceux qui ont
recours de manière indu aux urgences et
ça c'est quelque chose qu'on est en
train de regarder avec les hôpitaux
quand vous avez des gens qui même pour
des petits bobo après deux trois fois
continue d'aller directement aux
urgences bah il faut pouvoir les
responsabiliser c'est-à-dire qui a un
rest à charge parce que sinon ça va pas
c'est ça le système
responsabilisation organisation du
système de soins et donc d'un système
qui évite les urgences en ville donc oui
on tiendra l'objectif parce qu'on a
réinvesti aussi massivement sur notre
hôpital maintenant ce qu'on va continuer
de faire durant cette année c'est
d'aider et surtout dans les grandes
villes où la vie est chère à mieux
recruter les paramédicaux parce que
malgré ces augmentations de salaire une
des difficultés qu'on voit dans les
grandes villes où c'est très cher de se
c'est beaucoup pour beaucoup
d'infirmiers d'infirmièr pour beaucoup
d'aide soignant ça reste très cher
d'habiter près de l'hôpital et donc là
on veut engager un travail et d'ailleurs
nos directeurs et directrices d'hôpitaux
le font avec les communes qui consistent
à essayer d'avoir des solutions de
logement pour ces derniers leur famille
et permettre de réengager parce que si
on a un problème aujourd'hui c'est qu'il
manque beaucoup encore quand on dit les
lits sont fermés c'est parce qu'on
n'arrive pas à recruter malgré ses
augmentations de salaire et dans les
grandes villes c'est beaucoup les
paramédicaux
voilà les minist j'ai répondu les
ministres c'est la vie politique et donc
ce qui compte c'est que le cap ne change
pas il a pas changé d' Yota la feuille
de route n'a pas changé l'investissement
est là je vous dire mieux vaut ce que je
suis en train de vous décrire qu'un seul
ministre sans investissement et sans
cap bonsoir monsieur le Président Jérémy
Trottin pour RMC une question toujours
sur la les consultations vous évoquez
tout à l'heure ce sujet en indiquant
qu'il fallait peut-être réfléchir
davantage aux patients qu'alac il y a
aussi un débat qui traîne depuis la fin
de l'été celui sur les franchises
médicales de doublement notamment à la
fois sur les consultations mais aussi
sur les boîtes de médicaments
aujourd'hui chaque Français lorsqu'il
achète une boîte de médicament payer une
franchise de 50 centimes le débat existe
allez-vous le doubler passer cette
franchise à 1 € cela permettrait je
crois de de d'un certain nombre
d'économie 800 millions d'euros de
recettes en plus pour les caises de la
sécurité sociale est-ce que vous pouvez
vous priver d'une telle recette et
deuxème question peut-être cette fois
toujours sur la question du pouvoir
d'achat j'ai pas très bien compris si
les Français aller voir leur électricité
augmenter de 10 % ou pas tout à l'heure
quand vous avvez répondu à la question
de mon collègue de TF1 parce qu'il l'a
pas formulé comme ça mais je peux vous
dire que je me suitit pas au
gouvernement pour faire pour faire les
annonces précises mais ce que je disais
c'est que l'électricité le prix va
revenir dans la norme mais surtout il
restera quel que soit ce que le
gouvernement annonce dans les prochains
jours substantiellement inférieur à ce
qui est payé en Allemagne en Espagne en
Italie ça faut le regarder aussi et donc
là où ça aurait dû augmenter de plus de
100 % l'année dernière ça augmentter de
25 % l'électricité et on va continuer
d'avoir un prix d'électricité nettement
inférieur à nos voisins sur votre
premier
point nous sommes un pays qui soigne
bien qui ne prévient pas assez et donc V
question me permet d'abord d'insister
sur un sujet qu'on n pas assez évoqué
même si on parle de santé je m'en
réjouis depuis tout à l'heure c'est que
dans la stratégie de santé que la
ministre aura à conduire auprès du
Premier ministre et qu'elle connaît bien
parce que elle l'a porté aussi aussi
dans sa ville dans son agglomération et
puis dans ses compétences
intérieures on doit beaucoup mieux
prévenir aujourd'hui on va développer
les diagnostics de santé pour les
enfants les adolescents et les adultes
on a massivement
développé la vaccination et on va
continuer pour par exemple pour le
papiomavirus et d'autres et donc on doit
beaucoup mieux
prévenir ce qui veut dire aussi qu'on
doit conjurer une forme de fatalité
français qui est qu'on consomme trop de
médecine en même temps qu'on a une des
médecines les plus
pas cons P mais c'est toujours pare
pasarent mag qu pas consmateur P c'est
contribuable P et donc au moment où de
manière sérieuse je vois ce que nos
compatriotes PEV dépenser pour les
forfait de téléphonie la vie quotidienne
dire qu'on va passer 50 CEN à 1 € pour
un
paet pour un
médicament de médic j'ai pas le
sentiment qu'on fait un crime terrible
je pense que ça responsabilise une bonne
mesure il faut responsabiliser sur la
consommation par contre ce qu'il faut
garder éé de justice c'est pours
compatriotes ont des Affe long duré des
maladi qui suppos des prescriptions
régulièut continuer de les protéger
sontég parce qu'on a mis un plafond sont
pas plus de 50 € par ça fa le garder
faire quelque chose de juste je crois
c'estd responsabilise la médecine le
soin les médicaments ça ne coûte pas
rien on prend déjà beaucoup en charge
quasiment tout et donc oui moi je pense
que c'est une bonne chose de passer de
50 centimes à 1 € par boîte de
médicament franchement ça ne me choque
pas quand je vois ce que coûte beaucoup
d'autres éléments de la vie quotidienne
qui sont moins essentiels que le
médicament quand il est prescrit ou
quand il est important et à côté de ça
on va continuer de protéger ceux qui ont
un besoin de consommation régulière
parce qu'ils ont des ction de longue
durée et ils continueront à avoir cette
protection parce qu'ils auront un
plafond de 50 € par an pour ce reste à
charge parce qu'il faut responsabiliser
c'est une bonne
chose Monsieur le président Olivier bu
RTL je voudrais revenir un instant sur
les questions qui concernent la la
jeunesse et en particulier les questions
pour les enfants vous avez dit nous
détermineront le bon usage de nos écrans
pour les enfants question simple est-ce
que vous voulez empêcher les enfants
d'accéder à des écrans mais surtout
comment quels sont les les leviers
publics pour cela comment réguler est-ce
que vous comptez sur les opérateurs ou
sur les les fabricants de de téléphone
pour cela et puis quelle tranche d'âge
visez-vous des plus jeunes jusqu'aux
adolescents jusqu'à quel âge merci pour
ces précisions bon c'est une question
qui est essentielle quiconque a des
enfants ou des
adolescents ne ne peut pas l'éluder ces
dernières années on a tous ensemble
beaucoup beaucoup avancé sur le sujet
avant il y avait quasiment pas de
régulation d'abord je constate un fait
c'est que tout le monde voit que les
enfants les ados passent du temps sur
les écran les usages changent l'écran
c'est souvent le téléphone le sien pour
un adolescent quand ses parents le lui
en achète sinon c'est celui de des
parents euxmêmes mais ça commence très
jeune et je regarde les chiffres qui
sont donnés par les scientifiques
sociologues les les cliniciens on a des
enfants de 2 ans et beaucoup qui passent
parfois plusieurs heures par jour devant
un écran on a c'est à peu près établi
des enfants qui avant 6 ans en
exposition
régulière et on a ensuite beaucoup de
nos adolescents et de nos jeunes qui ont
accès au savoir à l'information à
l'actualité uniquement par les
écrans tout ça et pour le coup pour
avoir réunir assembler passer du temps à
écouter les meilleurs expert c'est pas
un avis politique c'est d'abord j'uris
demandé un consensus scientifique ça un
impact passer du temps devant un écran
ça a un impact sur le développement
affectif sensoriel cognitif d'un
enfant passer du temps dans un écran et
accéder à l'information très jeune sans
avoir des repères sans savoir comment
hiérarchiser l'information la classifier
avoir des bases ça donne un rapport à la
vérité à la
contrevérité qui est une vraie un vrai
sujet pour nos démocraties ça revient
d'ailleurs à ce que je disais sur le bon
ordre la manière d'apprendre l'histoire
l'instruction civique et autres et donc
c'est c'est un continent cognitif
affectif de construction du savoir qui
est très important pour l'équilibre de
nos enfants et de nos adolescents et qui
est très important aussi pour la
solidité de nos démocrati parce que si
on a des adolescents et des futurs
citoyens dont le rapport à la vérité a
été mal bâti en tout cas construit sur
des réseaux sociaux où la différence
entre la vérité et la contreevérité
était pas
claire bonjour la génération des
complotistes et même pour la génération
d'avant on n pas totalement réussi à le
conjurer on en a tous fait
l'expérience alors on a commencé on a
bien vu que tout ça et en plus de ça les
écrans évidemment expos aussi à des
phénomènes de société qui font souffrir
nos jeunes et nos ados on en a parlé
pour le harcèlement scolaire et le
iarcèlement qui Contin continu en ligne
on a commencé à faire oùou on en a parlé
pour l'exposition à la pornographie et
l'usage de le mauvais usage des contenus
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait ces dernières
années on a une approche d'abord par les
contenus donc on a défini au niveau
européen majorité à 15 ans on a commencé
à bâtir des textes on a sanctionné mis
une responsabilité et l'Europe est aux
avant-postes sur ce sujet les autres
continents ne font pas ça mais on a mis
une responsabilité des diffuseurs de
contenu on a accru justement la
protection de nos enfants et cetera et
cetera on a interdit je vous le rappelle
le portable au collège c'était un de mes
engagements de 2017 on a mis en place
grâce à nos
parlementaires un contrôle parental sur
les
téléphones en demandant justement aux
opérateurs et au constr strructeur de
téléphone de mettre en place des
forfaits des téléphones qui ne
permettent pas d'avoir accès à certains
services à supposer que les parents
achètent bien un téléphone pour leurs
adolescents et neurprête pas le leur il
y a pas de système parfait là ce que
j'ai voulu avec cette commission qui est
installée qui rendra ses travaux fin
mars c'est d'abord établir un consensus
scientifique c'est-à-dire qu'on éclaire
le débat public qu'est-ce que la science
nous dit sur les impacts sur nos enfants
et nos adolescents des écrans deux que
de manière scientifique les meilleurs
experts nous disent est-ce qu'il y a des
règles de base est-ce qu'il y a
peut-être vont-ils nous dire avant tel
âge donc moi je peux pas vous répondre
aujourd'hui je vous le dis en toute
humilité mais je veux que les meilleurs
scientifiques il y a à la fois des
épidémiologistes des cliniciens des
sociologues on a pris toutes les
disciplines puisse nous dire avant tel
âge ça n'est pas raisonnable de mettre
un écran devant un enfant entre tel âge
et tel âge c'est pour tel usage avec un
maximum de tendeur par jour faut
accompagner les familles on a laissé
beaucoup de familles sans mode
d'emploi c'est ça la réalité et on a
tous dit c'est bien de développer les
écrans dès le primaire pour accéder au
savoir mais on n pas mis de limite et
donc il faut un qu'on ait un consensus
scientifique de que les scientifiques
commencent à nous donner not et qu'on
éclaire un débat public qui viendra
ensuite et donc il y aura peut-être des
interdiction il y aura peut-être des
restrictions il y aura peut-être aussi
des restrictions sur les contenus et il
y aura je l'espère un bon usage de
l'utilisation des écrans pour toutes les
raisons que je viens
d'évoquer bonsoir monsieur le
président louyuse alterre du Figaro euh
il y a 6 mois de violentes et mutes on
ont éclaté dans le pays et ont beaucoup
marqué les Français à l'époque vous
n'avez pas apporté de réponse immédiate
vous avez dit vouloir prendre le temps
de comprendre les ressorts profonds de
ce qui s'est passé nous sommes 6 mois
après alors quelle lecture faites-vous
de ces événements est-ce que comme la
droite vous faites un lien avec
l'immigration ou en tout cas avec un
échec de l'intégration et est-ce que
vous pensez que les mesures que vous
venez d'annoncé sur la jeunesse euh vont
suffire à éviter que ça ne se reproduise
ou est-ce que vous comptez apporter des
réponses plus spécifi
je pense par exemple au service national
universel à une éventuelle
généralisation c'estàdire une obligation
pour toute une tranche d'âge je vous
remercie merci beaucoup d'évoquer cette
question vous avez raison d'y revenir
j'essaie de qualifier les émeutes qu'on
a eu l'été dernier d'abord jeis dire que
ces émeutes elles ont eu en face d'elles
une réponse implacable de l'état des
forces de sécurité intérieure les TR
nuits et de la justice c'est un record
d'interpellation condamnation donc la
réponse a été implacable et sans qu'on
ait besoin de déclarer quelque état
d'urgence ou autre il y a pas eu de
molesse maintenant j'essaie de voir ce
qu'il y a parce qu'on a voulu tout de
suite dire c'est un problème
d'immigration c'est un problème de ceci
de cela 500 villes ont connu ces émeutes
la moitié était des villes avec des
Cartier politique de la ville la moitié
non donc quelque chose s'est passé qui
était quand même pas totalement dans
notre cartographie habituelle est-ce que
c'est un problème d'immigration comme
j'ai dit je ne fais pas partie de ceux
qui disent qu'il y a pas de problème
d'immigration c'est pour ça que j'ai
assumer qu'on porte une loi c'est un
sujet il faut mieux maîtriser nos
frontières lutter contre l'immigration
clandestine est-ce que c'est la réalité
ce qu'on a vu sur le terrain non c'était
des jeunes de nationalité française pour
une quasi totalité née en France qui a
un problème d'intégration derrière oui
pas besoin des émeutes pour le savoir
oui et qui va des deux côtés parce qu'on
a encore trop d'assignation à résidence
et parce qu'on n' pas été assez
rigoureux sur certains points et ce
qu'on mène en matière de rénovation
urbaine en matière d'éducation en
matière d' à la culture au sport et en
matière justement aussi d'opportunités
économique pour moi dois y coner mais
c'est plus compliqué ce qui s'est passé
quand j'ai parlé au maire dans les 500
communes où il y a eu ce ces émeutes
d'abord elles sont intervenues fin
juin c'était beaucoup de très jeunes qui
étaient dans les rues et c'était des
jeunes c'est une erreur qu'on a
commise qui était souvent sans école
depuis le mois
d'avril réforme du brevet réforme du
baccalauréat l'organisation commune le
système tel qui marche plus de classe
loisiveté c'est les vieux précett
parfois disent beaucoup c'était des
jeunes qui ont pas la chance d'avoir des
familles qui les emmènent à la mer à la
montagne qui justement ont pas assez
accès à la culture au sport il
s'ennuyent il y a eu un événement
déclencheur la mort d'un jeune je ne
parlerai pas de ce qui est en cours et
dans c'était dans le cadre d'une
opération policière on s'en souvient
tous des jeunes ma
et l'enquête est en cours donc je ne
veux pas en dire plus là-dessus mais ça
a été l'élément déclencheur mais il y
avait
ça des jeunes sans activité très jeune
et ensuite les écrans ont eu un rôle
très important qu'on avait jamais vu
c'est-à-dire en quelques minutes on
voyait des centaines d'actions se
déployaient des rendez-vous donnés sur
tel ou tel je ferai pas de
stigmatisation réseau social par l'écran
et il y a eu une forme de mimétisme qui
a conduit à un embrasement totalement
déraisonné et ça a été une forme des
meut totalement nouvelles qu'on a vécu
des jeunes très jeunes qui allaient par
l'école qui étaient tous derrière leurs
écrans qui utilisaient des écrans pour
se rassembler et qui en quelque sorte se
lançit des défis par écran et qui était
cette génération un peu que j'évoqué
tout à l'heure donc vous voyez bien que
la réponse
elle peut pas être univoque c'est pour
ça que j'ai pas voulu céder à
l'injonction du moment est-ce que la
réponse c'est l'immigration c'est la la
lutte contre l'immigration non il faut
lu apporter mais c'est pas une réponse
aux émeutes est-ce que la réponse
c'était plus de policiers non on a
recréé on avait recréé déjà et dans ces
villes elles avaient toutes plus de
policiers que 2 ans avant toutes est-ce
que la réponse éétait plus
d'investissement politique de la ville
ce que disait disait de l'autre côté
c'est pas vrai on avait plus de
programmes de l'Agence nationale de
rénovation urbaine dans toutes ces
villes il y a jamais eu autant de Gru
dans ces villes jamais j'ai plus que
doublé le budget de l'enrue durant le
premier mandat il est passé de 5 à 12
milliards d'engagement donc les réponses
faciles de gauche et de droite classique
que j'ai vu selon les orientations des
après tout faux réponse plus compliquée
et donc la réponse c'est de se dire 1 on
doit réengager avec les familles c'est
ce que je disais je veux pas ici rentrer
dans le détail être trop long
accompagner familles pour les aider ce
qu'on a commencé avec les000 les 1000
premiers jours mais on a besoin
d'accompagner certaines familles 60 % de
ces jeunes venaient de famille
monoparental ça c'est un continent caché
on a commencé à y répondre dans premier
quinquena avec les aides parce que
beaucoup de ces mamans seules 95 % sont
des mamans
souvent le payz pas la pension on a
apporté des réponses par nos réformes
mais on voit bien
quand une famille monoparental élève un
jeune de jeun TR adolescen c'est très
dur donc on doit les aider et les
responsabiliser ensuite on a un sujet
sur l'accompagnement des jeunes qui
commen à
décrocher avoir une réponse plus adaptée
dans le système scolaire mais aussi
avoir une réponse je dirais prpénal puis
pénal qui est plus CLA ça fait partie
des choses qu'on est en train de
préparer
on a l'accès au sport et à la culture
essentiel pour ces jeunes on a
réorganisé déjà ça c'est une réponse à
ces émeutes le temps scolaire ils iront
tous jusqu'en juillet il y aura plus de
temps scolaire qui est perdu en mai et
en juin et ça c'est essentiel de le
tenir les écrans la réponse arrive et
donc c'est un
ensemble c'est un problème beaucoup plus
compliqué dans ce contexte là oui le
service national universel fait partie
de la réforme c'est pourquoi j'aurai
l'occasion d'y revenir dans les
prochaines semaines mais nous irons vers
la généralisation du service national
universel en
seconde il est cohérent avec ce que je
viens de vous
décrire bonsoir monsieur le Président
Laurence ferrar c'est news europea par
image vous nous avez gratifié d'un
certain nombre de mesures de détails
c'est important ce qui nous intéresse
c'est la vision que vous avez pour notre
pays pour les 3 ans à venir la fin de
notre mandat à nos yeux ce qui est
important c'est sans doute l'éducation
nationale qui qui concentre tous les
enjeux toutes les fractures de notre
société nous avons l'éducation nationale
la plus chère au monde au classement
PISA vous le savez nous ne brillons pas
notamment en ma au capesses de math nous
avons du mal à recruter il y a plus de
que postees que de candidats vous voulez
qu'il chante la Marseillaise
pratiquement un jeune sur deux ne sait
pas situer la Révolution française ne
connaît pas la Choa ne sait pas ce qui
s'est passé le jour de la rafle du
veldive 48 % des professeurs disent se
censurer lorsqu'ils enseignent
l'histoire dans leur classe un sur deux
à peur en classe peur de la violence des
élèves des parents et des terroristes je
pense ce soir à Samuel pati et Dominique
Bernard vous voulez restaurer l'autorité
la France doit rester la France bien sûr
comment faire de ces jeunes des citoyens
éclairés donnez-moi cinq mesures
concrètes pour restaurer cette autorité
soutenir les parents c'est bien les
responsabiliser c'est mieux aussi et
puis il y a 17 % des parents qui ont
fait le choix du privé c'est fort
honorable après tout est-ce que la
guerre école privée école publique n'a
pas été relancée par votre MX de
l'éducation nationale merci pour votre
réponse j'ai le sentiment de donner une
vision et des mesures concrètes je crois
que vous venez vous-même de poser une
question et de donner votre vision
et ceci étant dit ceci étant dit les
mesures concrètes je vous les ai donné
il y a pas d'écoes qui tiennent s'il y a
pas des professeurs bien
formés refondre de la formation des
enseignants des mars on a des concours
on sait qu'ils ne sont pas tous pour vu
parce que le système aujourd'hui il est
pas adapté on a des professeurs
remarquables remarquables et je veux pas
qu'on aille vers la stymatisation de de
nos enseignants loin de là on doit mieux
les payer ce qu'on a commencé de faire
on va continuer le PACT on doit mieux
les former la deuxième mesure très
concrète c'est de poursuivre le choc des
savoirs pourquoi les les résultats PISA
sont mauvais et parce que les résultats
PISA sont faits sur des classes qui
n'ont pas été touchés par les réformes
qu'on a conduitite au prier ququena donc
je veux bien payer pour tout le monde
déjà ce qu'on fait pour la santé et
autes c'est ce qui a pas été prévu par
il y a 20 ans mais ceux qui ont été
testés à la réforme PISA ils ont eu à
vivre la réforme du collège qui avait
été
décidé avant
2017 attendons ceux qui ont eu à suivre
et les tests nous montrent que
d'ailleurs on a des élèves qui ont
beaucoup mieux résisté en primaire grâce
au dédoublement et ce qu'on a à faire et
le ministre a apporté la réponse donc
moi j'assume vous me parlez de résultats
qui ne sont pas liés aux réformes qu'on
a faites qu'est-ce que c'est la bonne
réponse pour avoir des élèves bien
formés après la réforme de
l'enseignement des professeurs leur
meilleur rémunération systme finir la
systématisation dédoublement des classes
pour les grandes sections de maternelle
après ce que nous avons fait pour CP CE
c'est l'évaluation fin d'année qu'on va
progressivement généraliser à tous les
niveaux on commencé l'année dernière
c'est essentiel parce que c'est ce qui
permet d'éviter le passage d'une
classeautre sans
avoir avoir la totale maîtrise de ce qui
était supposé et Rem dédoublement à
l'initiative des professeurs dans les
classes
charnières ce qui a été décidé pour le
CM2 et avec un brevet qui a du sens
qu'il faut réviser et qui est une
condition de passage au
collège 4ème point qui est indispensable
c'est l'instruction civique et
l'instruction civique qui ne soit pas un
ensemble de connaissance de nature
diverse et qui est enseigné de manière
inégale sur le territoire avec l'URE
obligatoire dès la 5e où on apprend les
textes fondamentaux où on apprend si
elle n'a pas été maîtrisée la
Marseillaise mais je souhaite qu'elle
soit enseignée dès le primaire je l'ai
déjà dit et où on apprend aussi les
grands textes qui font notre histoire ce
sont des mesures très concrètes et j'en
ai donné d'autres dans mon propos
introductif donc oui il faut continuer
d'avancer on a depuis
2017 commencé à rebattir l'école on
s'est attaqué là au collège il y a toute
la réforme aussi de l'orientation et on
s'attaque aussi au lycée professionnel
dont on parle peu mais qui touche un
tiers de nos lycéens qui est
indispensable et sur lequel aussi on est
en train de conduire une vraie petite
révolution des
savoirs moi moi je suis un enfant des
deux écoles comme disent les grands
auteurs j'ai été à la laïque et à
l'école privée sous contrat j'y ai vu
des professeurs engagés à qui je dois
beaucoup donc je pense qu'il y a pas de
conflit entre les deux écoles à avoir
que la la France la République est forte
de tous ces systèmes ce qu'il faut c'est
engager tout le monde dans les mêmes
exigences et donc il faut que partout on
puisse avoir d'abord on juge pas les
gens sur leur choix individuel moi je
pense que le choix de l'école où on met
ses enfants c'est un choix privé on n
pas jugé les gens à leur faire des procè
dessus et ensuite on doit tout faire
pour qu'on ait une école publique qui
soit au meilleurs standard et qui soit
forte une école privée sous contrat qui
soit la plus forte possible et qui
respecte parfaitement les règles de la
République et c'est aussi pour ça qu'on
a besoin d'une école privée sous contrat
qui s'engage au côté de l'école publique
pour ouvrir des classes ULIS pour
accompagner les enfants en difficulté
pour avoir des se pas et cetera et
cetera c'est ça le bon système
voilà donc les polémiques du ne doivent
pas nous faire
quitter l'axe qui est le nôtre la
réussite de nos enfants une école forte
c'est un des fondements de la
République bonsoir monsieur le Président
Justine guittion pour reporter vous avez
évoqué l'avenir des générations futures
depuis que vous avez créé le Haut
Conseil pour le climat en 2019 tous les
rapports annuels ont montré que les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre ne
bais ne baissait pas suffisamment
vite donc comment comptez-vous atteindre
les objectifs climatiques européens
2030- 2050 vous avez évoqué ce soir le
leasing la rénovation des bâtiments
c'est des annonces que vous aviez déjà
faites il y a 6 mois voire il y a 1 an
donc globalement quelle nouvelle
politique écologique vous pouvez nous
annoncer concrètement ce soir sachant
que Gabriel Atal n'a pas n'a quasiment
pas encore évoqué la planification
écologique que su erreur de ma part
Christophe Béchu n'est pas là ce soir et
qu'il n'y a plus de ministère de la
transition énergétique quelle nouvelle
politique écologique vous pouvez nous
annoncer ce
soir d'abord je je plaide l'indulgence
pour le Premier ministre qui n'a pas pu
évoquer tous les sujets et même celui-ci
qui continue d'être dans son
titre et qui aura l'occasion d'y revenir
dans les prochains jours sa déclaration
de politique générale quant au ministre
précisément parce qu'il est en charge et
qu'il ne vous a pas échappé qu'on a
beaucoup de territoires qui sont touché
je pense à nos compatriotes de la
Réunion nos compatriotes du pas decalis
il est mobilisé sur le terrain il avait
aussi des obligations
parlementaires je vais être clair parce
que je là aussi c'est comme ce que je
disais pour la santé moi je crois au Cap
aux mesures claires et après à leur mise
en œuvre je vais pas vous annoncer
aujourd'hui un nouveau cap écologique
parce que je pense qu'on a pris des
décisions historiques et qu'elles sont
les bonnes j'ai pris un
engagement d'abord qui était de faire
une nation plus forte plus industrielle
et décarboné vous avez cité les rapports
du Haut Conseil pour le climat soyons
collectivement honnête il nous a dit
qu'on était on allait pas assez vite
pour les années à venir mais il a
reconnu les résultats ils sont
d'ailleurs publqu des années passées
durant quen précédent on est revenu sur
la trajectoire des accords de Paris et
nous avons doublé les réductions
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre
doublé c'est-à-dire qu'alors même qu'on
a recréé 2 millions d'emplois qu'on a
rouvert 300 usines en net qu'on a
commencé à rindustrialisé le pays on a
été deux fois plus vite sur la baisse
des émissions comme quoi ce qui nous
explique qu'il faudrait fermer tel ou
tel
pour respecter la trajectoire climat pas
vrai ce que nous a dit le Conseil climat
il a dit pour tenir votre engagement
dans les années qui viennent faut aller
2,5 fois plus vite tout à fait vrai ben
je constate que les chiffres qui sont à
ma disposition pour l'année qui vient de
s'écouler sont dans cette ligne faut
passer de 2% à 5 % par an on a été de 2
% par an entre 2018 et 2022 on est à
4,6% sur
2023 donc ce qu'on a fait pour l'AC
croître est en train de fonctionner la
stratégie décrite à Marseille c'est quoi
Premier ministre qui pilote la
planification écologique et énergétique
c'est toujours le cas ce sont dans ses
attributions on a créé pour la première
fois dans l'histoire de notre République
une administration qui lui est attachée
pour cela un secrétariat général
pourquoi parce que c'est
interministériel les efforts se font
dans tous les secteurs ensuite on a
travaillé pendant 1 an à une
planification là aussi inédit et on a
défini les efforts à faire et les
actions concrètes dans chaque
secteur maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on est
en train de faire on la territorialise
et donc dans chaque région on a mis en
place une COP justement de cette
planification et on est en train de
bâtir des projets avec chaque commune
intercommunalité métropole département
et région pour pouvoir déployer les
bonnes actions et donc il y a pas une
solution miracle il y a pas une annonces
fracassante il y a les dizaines de
milliards d'euros qu'on investit chaque
année pour accompagner cette transition
pour qu'elle soit juste et des stratégie
locale qu'on va développer c'est qui nos
fameux services métropolitain de
transport collectif pour permettre de
moins recourir à la voiture individuelle
et avoir des transports hydrogènes ou
électriques et on est en train de les
déployer on a eu la carte elle a été
annoncée c'est accompagné on a des
records d'adhésion au véhicules hybrid
ou électrique c'est le changement de
véhicule il faut le faire avec le bonus
écologique qui a beaucoup augmenté
maintenant le leasing qui commence à se
déployer c'est on sait en effet la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments il
faut continuer de simplifier la prime
qui existe mais là on y met beaucoup
d'argent et on va continuer de le faire
et puis ensuite c'est secteur par
secteur et l'un des secteurs où on a
beaucoup investi l'année dernière c'est
aussi celui de l'industrie parce qu'on a
identifié que sur 50 sites industriels
si on faisait l'effort on faisait
quasiment la moitié de ce qu'on doit
faire sur l'ensemble de notre industrie
et donc on a mis on a accéléré les
effort faits pour décarboner nos
cimenteries nos ports nos assyries et
cetera et on signe des contrats avec nos
industriel et C pour permettre justement
de continuer d'avoir des emplois et de
moins émettre c'est une stratégie dans
ble donc là aujourd'hui le temps il est
plus aux annonces il est à faire sur le
terrain à évaluer mois par mois et donc
la priorité dans les prochains mois sur
la planification écologique et ben c'est
de déployer le plan qui est le nôtre sur
le terrain à côté de ça j'avais à
belellefort annoncé une stratégie
énergétique et là-dessus on a une force
la France est un des pays d'Europe qui a
l'énergie la plus décarbonée grâce au
nucléaire j'ai annoncé et là aussi en
créant les conditions
consensus scientifique puis politique
tout le monde l'a oublié il y a 6 ans
personne nétait d'accord sur le
nucléaire rappelez-vous les débats qu'on
avait j'ai demandé un rapport au
meilleurs experts et j'ai été à bfort
entouré de forces Politi qui s'oppos sur
ce sujet guerre on a annoncé une
nouvelle stratégie on redéploie du
nucléaire et on réploie du renouvelable
et là aussi on est au travaux Prati j'ai
annoncé les sites des nouveau réacteurs
les travx les ement et tout le travail
commence à EDF à l'été
j'annoncerai les grands axes pour les 8
prochains et c'est de la mise en œuvre
et on l'a fait pareil sur le
renouvelable avec nos stratégies pour
déployer l'éolien en mer et cetera et
cetera c'est de la mise en œuvre mais
les résultats des 6 dernières années
sont bons les résultats des derniers
mois montrent que on a doublé le taux
d'effort on a une stratégie une
organisation faut de l'efficacité des
résult et maintenant la territorialisé
c'estd travailler avec nos
élus bonsoir monsieur le Président
Julien lcuyer de la voie du Nord je vais
vous citer un chiffre 98,5 % c'est c'est
le pourcentage de la surface de Calais
qui pourrait être submergé par la mer
dans les dizaines d'années à venir
quelques dizaines d'années à venir 82 %
de la surface de duncarc aussi alors
question simple c'est que vaudra la
stratégie de réindustrialis tion si les
gigafactory ont les pieds dans l'eau que
vaudra la politique de de décarbonation
si harcelmital et noyé sous les sous les
EAU on a des milliers de nos habitants
du du pas decalais qui sont actuellement
touchés par les les intempérie que leur
dites-vous est-ce que vous leur dites
comme le votre ministre de la transition
écologique qu'il faudra peut-être à
terme déménager merci alors d'abord je
veux
aussi redire à nos compatriotes dans le
Pas de calis qui vivent depuis
maintenant des mois une situation
terrible notre soutien j'ai été auprès
d'eux il y a quelques semaines ministre
de l'intérieur comme le ministre de la
transition ils sont allés à plusieurs
reprises le Premier ministre il a fait
son premier déplacement il reviendra à
la fin du
mois je vais leur dire notre soutien
complet entier mais c'est épuisant ce
qu'ils vivent parce qu'ils ont vu la
montée des eaux les inondations l'eau
qui ne descend pas puis les
précipitations à nouveau et donc c'est
épuisant pour les Ners et ils vivent
dans des maisons qui ont parfois un m
d'eau parfois ils ils ont tout perdu et
donc un on va continuer à intensifier
nos efforts pour pomper et pour évacuer
cette eau deux évidemment on sera à leur
côté pour restaurer au plus vite et là
aussi avec de la simplification et un
pilotage sur le terrain avec la Région
le Département et et les maires au plus
près et puis on sera à leur côté aussi
pour indemniser et mettre la pression
sur les assurances et accompagner les
particuliers comme les commerçants et
les entrepreneurs et les
agriculteurs on sera là mais le problème
que vous posez est une réalité je
l'évoqué de manière rapide dans mon
propos introductif c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'adaptation et c'est tout à
fait vrai que quels que soient les
efforts qu'on fait pour baisser nos
émissions pour changer nos manières de
produire de consommer et cetera et nous
mettre en conformité avec la stratégie
de Paris nous aurons à vivre les
conséquences du dérèglement climatique
il est déjà là et donc on doit s'adapter
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
qu'on va devoir changer nos villes nos
paysages nos régions pour faire face à
des événements climatiques auxquels elle
n'était pas habitué ça veut dire que
dans beaucoup de nos villes on va devoir
faire face au forte chaleur qui vont
plus être simplement un ou deux jours
par an c'est les îlos de chaleur qu'on
crée c'est de la végétalisation des
vides c'est une organisation différente
ça veut dire que on va progressivement
adapter nos villes nos paysages et là
faut le faire avec le beau et le
résistant si je puis dire c'est ça cette
stratégie d'adaptation qu'on va bâtir il
y a aucune fatalité et je le dis très
clairement à nos compatriotes d'
haut-fance on continuera à vivre er à
Cal on continuera à vivre dans l'odarois
et on pourra vivre être heureux au Mara
comme dans le mon qui met aussi cher et
qui souffre aussi beaucoup comment en
adaptant il y aura peut-être des
endroits où on devra créer des
interdictions mais surtout on doit
repenser aussi ce qu'on avait
oublié ceux qui d'ailleurs travaillent
ou vivent dans le Maré à SaintOmer ou
ailleurs me rappele quand j'y suis
allé avant l'évacuation vers la mer se
faisait beaucoup plus simplement les
watering fonctionnaient mieux on
avait on curait plus simplement les
cours d'eau et on avait un accès à la
mer qui était qui allait beaucoup plus
vite qui évacuait plus de mètres cubes
parce que le port était plus adapté et
le temps à travers le temps il y a
certains investissements qui n'ont pas
été faits nos règles se complexifiant le
coût de certaines opérations augmentent
et là où on le faisait avec les les
collègues où c'était simple et pas cher
de le faire on a créé tell l qu'on le
fait plus c'est ça ce qui s'est passé
progressivement c'est pour ça qu'on a
d'ailleurs confié au maire de Saint-Omer
une mission pour s'inspirer des
meilleures pratiques européennes et
regarder comment on va faciliter
l'écoulement de l'eau vers la mer donc
il y a des réponses l'adaptation il y a
des réponses et parfois il y a des
réponses vous savez de bon sens que les
gens qui vivent sur ces territoire
connaissent bien mieux que beaucoup je
rentre dans le détail très concret c'est
la vie des gens aller dans l'odomarois
que j'évoqué dans le CAL dans le derqua
les gens ils savent très bien ce qu'il
faut faire pour les plus anciens pour
ceux qui étaient les travaux à faire sur
le port les investissements à faire sur
certaines digues Comment curer certains
rues ou ailleurs comment améliorer le
système des voitringues ou les pompes et
cetera c'est ce qu'on va faire mais plus
largement on va avoir une adaptation de
nos paysages de nos villes pour faire
face à tout cela on aura une adaptation
aussi dans le grand Ouest qui vit déjà
le décalage du trait de côte en région
nouvellequitaine vous avez déjà
aujourd'hui des gens qui aujourd'hui en
effet ont leur leur maison parfois leur
entreprise qui est bousculée par le
recul du trait de côte adaptation donc
on sera là pour accompagner c'est un
investissement de la nation c'est un
changement de beaucoup de nos habitudes
mais on sera là et je veux avoir une
approche optimiste
elle est pas naïve c'est un
investissement qu'on a déjà commencé à
faire on va l'accélérer mais par du bon
sens la simplification de certaines
normes l'innovation qu'on va déployer
sur le terrain grâce à nos paysagistes
grâce à de l'innovation industrielle
grâce à certains investissements on
adaptera nos territoires en France
hexagonal comme ultramarine à
l'évolution des
risques bonsoir monsieur le Président
Benjamin duamel pour pour BFM TV en 2017
le soir de votre élection vous disiez
vouloir je cite tout faire pour qu'il
n'y ait plus aucune raison de voter pour
les extrêmes et pourtant la liste menée
par Jordane Bardella est en tête de tous
les sondages pour les élections
européennes Marine Le Pen et Jordan
Bardella s'imagine carrément déjà se
partageant les rôles l'une à votre place
à l'Élysée l'autre à matigon quelle part
de responsabilité prenez-vous dans cette
progression n'est-ce pas un aveu d'échec
quant à 2027 ne craignez-vous pas de
voir votre héritage politique totalement
entacher si dans 3 ans et demi vous
laissez les clés de l'Élysée à Marine Le
Pen
d'abord les ambitions que vous prêtez au
responsable politique évoqué sont pas
une
nouveauté il m'a semblé que lors des
deux dernières campagne présidentielle
intéressé se voyit au même endroit je me
félicite d'avoir pu empêcher cette
opération et je ferai tout pour le
continuer parce que je pense que c'est
bon pour le pays ensuite je regarde
autour de nous dans toutes les
démocraties européennes y compris chez
nos voisins allemands où on pensait
impossible le retour de l'extrême droite
elle est là donc je pense qu'il faut pas
le voir simplement avec nos yeux
franco-français quelque chose se
passe moi je pense qu'il faut pour
éviter le retour des extrêmes en
particulier de l'extrême droite
s'attaquer à ce qui fait voter pour eux
la première chose c'était le chômage de
masse c'était une spéci une spécificité
française nous étions à coup sûr la plus
la grande économie qui n'avait pas
réussi à endiguer celui-ci on est en
train de le faire et on va continuer la
désindustrialisation on le voyait dans
nos territoires de l'Est comme du Nord
avait beaucoup nourr Rassemblement
National Front national nagur on est en
train d'y répondre on améliore
d'ailleurs les choses dans ces
territoirees est-ce que c'est suffisant
non
deè élément
l'immigration lutter contre
l'immigration clandestine c'est je pense
une des
répes remblement national c'est pouroi
j'asse totalement la politique au niveau
européen et françaison a mais le faire
dans leadre dere
républiquep que je mais faut s'attaquer
à ça qui dans certain
régionè ch qui je pense c'est une forme
de sentiment dépossession beaucoup de
nos compatriotes se disent au fond le
pays marche plus on a tout essayé on les
a pas essayé et ma crainte et ce contre
quoi je me bat parce que je suis pas là
pour craindre vous me
direz c'est que tout le monde s'habitue
à ça et plus personne ne dit que le
rassemblement national comme toutes les
extrêmes droite en Europe c'est surtout
et avant tout le pays de
l'appauvrissement collectif c'est le
pays c'est le pays c'est parti de
parti du mensonge et ça continue de
l'être c'est le parti qui a le programme
qui complè piquer à l'extrême gauche
c'est partie qui continue à vous
expliquer que la retraite à 60 ans est
possible sans vous expliquer comment la
financer partie qui vous explique qu'il
faut augmenter le SPIC sans vous
expliquer comment ça désindustrialisera
pas le pays c'est le parti qui continue
de vous expliquer des choses impossibles
sur le plan économique et social pour
affaiblir si on s'attaque pas pied à
pied à l'incohérence de leur programme
là les gens se disent disent des trucs
faciles l'opposition c'est beaucoup plus
facile que le gouvernement donc faut
aller au réel sur ce qu'il propose
et ça c'est notre responsabilité
collective ça n'est pas que la mienne
seule mais tant qu'on continuera à avoir
un discours politique qui parfois est
déréalisé pas populaire de faire une
réforme des retraites ou de l'assurance
chômage mais si on continue à aller voir
les gens et qu'on trouve que c'est
formidable et que c'est une réponse
politique de leur dire on va continuer
de vous aider on va vous remettre la
retraite à 60 ans tout va bien se passer
ou à 62 ans maintenant puis la deuxème
chose c'est le parti du
transformisme c'està-dire qu'il y a 6
ans et demi
l'EUR et de l'EUR et maintenant il est
pour rester mais pour plus en respecter
les traités comme l'extrême gauche même
programme c'est le C c'estissement de la
France
aussi je plusop s deou sortir de comme
Guer ENF nouster pas les
traitveousz c'est quoi que vous
connaissezprpriété on continue à vous
payer l' gaz mais vous respectez rien
c'est le programme faut le dire faut se
battre et dans un monde en bascule comme
je viens de l'évoquer face à la Chine
aux États-Unis d'Amérique vous pensez
qu'un une France tout seule dans une
Europe affaiblie c'est une bonne chose
c'est ça le programme du rassemblement
national mais si tout le monde s'habitue
en disant ils sont devenus sympathiques
en fait ils disent plus des choses qui
nous heurtent parce qu'on sait plus trop
ce qu'ils disent moi je vois le débat
public sait plus trop ce qu'ils disent
enfin ils sont contre ce que fait le
gouvernement ça a l'air
sympa là à ce moment-là
on rentre dans un une forme de zone de
danger qu'on voit dans tous les pays
européens parce qu'on ne se bat plus P à
pied sur ce qui est la réalité de nos
principes c'est pour ça que moi
j'assume de continuer à présider au réel
avec un certain sens de l'idéal et dire
quand les gens ont un problème on essaie
de le résoudre au concret au réel qu'on
essaie de tendre le coup au mensonges
qu'on a besoin en effet d'une France
plus forte et plus juste mais qui
s'appuie sur des réalités d'une
politique économique qui a des résultats
parce qu' a un sens et une cohérence que
ne propose pas le rassemblement national
d'une politique écologique qui a un sens
et une cohérence parce qu'elle est
compatible avec la création d'emploi
d'une politique d'ordre républicain
juste et ferme et qui respecte notre été
et notre Constitution c'est tout
l'inverse du rassemblement national donc
on va continuer de se battre mais je
vois partout en Europe celui-ci qui
monte par une forme de fascination du
désastre mais par un affaiblissement du
débat collectif parce qu'on oublie tous
de revenir au réel et à la réalité de
les arguments et là on va avoir un vrai
débat
européen je suis pas heureux de voir en
tête des sondages parce que moi j'ai
beaucoup fait pour qu'on soit plus fort
nous Français en Europe depuis 5 ans et
que notre Europe a beaucoup avancé mais
rassurezv l'EUR du rassemblement
national c'est pas celle qui vous
permettra d'avoir les vaccins je
rappelle pendant la crise covid on a des
vaccins dans notre pays parce qu' avait
l'urope on a pu faire un plan de relance
parce avait l'Europe on peut aujourd'hui
peser face à la Chine au États-Unis
d'Amérique parce qu' l'Europe parce qui
porte nos valeurs on sait poussé nos
projets et notre ambition mais parce
qu'elle est là c'est l'inverse de ce que
porte le rassemblement national et au
fond rassemblement national est devenu
le parti de la colère
facile on n pas tout essayé ça paraî
sympathique ne nous habituons pas
agissons
fais bousculons les choses et habitudes
pour montrer qu'en effet ce bloc central
qui rassemble les démocrates les
républicains les écologistes qui croient
dans l'Europe peut agir et changer les
choses et le quotidien des gens ayons
parfois l'honnêteté de dire quand ça
marche la lucidité de dire quand ça
marche pas et avançons c'est ça pour moi
la bonne réponse je me battrai jusqu'au
dernier quart d'heure je me suis
toujours battu comme ça pas avec des
leçon de morale en regardant le pays tel
qu'il est en essayant de convaincre avec
des arguments des actions et du réel
c'est ça le meilleur
moyen d'éviter les extrêmes et j'y crois
et si vous lui laissez la place pas j'en
ai jamais fait j'en ai jamais fait en
campagne je vais pas en faire ici vous
savez j'ai compris qu'il y avait
beaucoup de gens qui s'énervaient sur
2027 enfin j'ai quand même compris aussi
qu'il me restait 3 ans et demi à
présider
et fort des 6 ans et demi que je viens
de vivre il se passe beaucoup de choses
en 3 ans et demi beaucoup de
choses monsieur le Président de la
République bonsoir Olivier beaumon du
Parisien Aujourd'hui en France la
question de Benjamin du Amel me laisse à
penser que nous venons de basculer dans
la partie plus politique de cette soirée
j'aimerais revenir du coup sur la
nomination de votre nouveau gouvernement
nous avons eu quelques surprises tout
d'abord celle de Gabriel Atal nommée
comme premier ministre et puis le retour
d'une figure sarkoziste Rach hadti qui
avait appartenu au gouvernement il y a
une dizaine d'années plusieurs questions
me viennent en tête tout d'abord
pourquoi le choix de de cette
personnalité à ce ministère làà deuxième
chose qu'est-ce qui a changé entre 2017
et aujourd'hui en 2017 François baayerou
qui avait été mis en examen avait dû
quitter le gouvernement rachti est
aujourd'hui mise en examen elle vient
d'être nommé au gouvernement et enfin
dernière question le sujet de Paris on
laisse à penser qu'il y aurait eu un
deal entre elle et vous concernant les
élections municipales en en 2027 dans la
capitale merci de nous apporter quelques
éclaircissements merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup d'abord je vais icied dire les
choses très
clairement François Baayou a pris la
décision démissionner je ne lui ai pas
demandé en 2017 il était garde des
sauts j'ai eu ensuite plusieurs
ministres durant mon premier mandat qui
ont été mis en
examen et et en effet ministre de la
Culture les dans une affaire don je n'ai
pas à connaître au f je me suis appuyé
sur un changement des règles simples et
aussi en regardant l'évolution de notre
vie politique et judiciaire depuis 10
ans maintenant dans notre pays il n'y a
plus instruction individuelle sur les
dossiers il y avait une vieille
jurisprudence qui existait dans notre
pays qui fait qu'en effet quand un
ministre était mis en examen il devait
quitter la table du Conseil parce qu'il
avait un de ses collègues qui pouvait
donner une instruction individuelle au
parquet c'est interdit maintenant il n'y
en a plus qui
plusit tous les membres du parquet que
j'ai eu à nommer depuis que je suis
président comme le faisait d'ailleurs
mon
prédécesseur l'ont été conformément aux
avis du
CSM donc oui ce faisant il y a pas de R
qui fait qu'un ministre mise en examen
devrait quitter parce que sinon en
quelque sorte je reconnaîtrai moin un
responsable politique la présempption
d'innocence d'aut il se trouve que
d'ailleurs j'ai pu avoir des ministres
mis en examen qui ensite on été innocent
m félicite pour monre plutôt que c'est
assz juste donc la justice va faire son
travail avec sérénité à son rythme mais
je considère qu'il y a pas de changement
de règle y a juste aussi une forme de
bon sens pour le
reste j'ai proposé avec le Premier
ministre madame Rachid devenir ministre
de la Culture parce que son énergie son
talent sa
liberté ne se réduit pas à une
appartenance
politique je crois util à la
culture à ouvrir des portes et à
permettre au fond de mettre fin je le
disais c'est pour moi mes grands
objectifs à cette France c'est pas fait
pour moi
faut lutter contre
celle-ci nous n'avons pas parlé de Paris
vous aurez du mal à me croire quand je
vous dis ça mais c'est
vrai la seule chose que je veux pour
Paris c'est qu'un électeur puisse avoir
les mêmes droit et compté autant à Paris
qu'à men à Besançon ou ailleurs et donc
que le gouvernement et le Parlement
puissent décider d'une réforme en
profondeur de la loi parislionmseille
pour revenir au droit commun ça je pense
que c'est la bonne chose c'est la seule
chose ce qui me concerne pour Paris le
reste je sais qu'elle mettra son talent
son énergie et tout le reste au service
de la culture de ceux qui la servent et
de ceux qui veulent aussi y avoir
droit monsieur le Président ah ici
Rachel garaccel pour 20 minutes vous
nous avez parlé de l'ordre avec
l'uniform à l'école une politique contre
la drogue alors que certains disent que
la prohibition ne ne fonctionne pas vous
nous avez parlé de politique nataliste
de cérémonie de remise des diplômes
est-ce que le gouvernement le plus jeune
avec le président le plus jeune ne vont
pas mener une politique
anacronique voir si vous me permettez un
peu vieux jeux en quoi c'est vieux
jeux cérémonie de remise des diplômes
uniformes est-ce que ce sont pas des
vieux débats je vois tous nos jeunes qui
regardent les séries télévisées où il y
a ses remis de diplôme et trouent ça
super je vois qu'on retrouve des rit
quand la République perd ses
rites d'autres rites sont inventés moi
je crois pas du tout que le symbo
soit vieux jeu je crois pas du je vais
vous
dire je je l'expliquis tout à l'heure en
disant ce qui a fait notre pays c'est
l'ordre et le progrès je crois qu'il y a
pas de progrès sans ordre et pour le
coup là on est vieux je s'il y a que
l'ordre et pas le progrès je crois à une
autorité juste et une émancipation nos
sociétés sont devenu un peu
liquides et donc faut redonner des
repères des repères par les savoirs
qu'on transmet par l'histoire qu'on
transmet par les valeurs qu'on transmet
fautedner des rendez-vous des Caps de
passage la fin du primaire le brevet des
collèges le
baccalauréat les diplomations c'est pas
vieux jeu du tout croyez-moi parce que
si on passe dans la vie comme ça comme
entre des courants tout le monde est
perdu et moi je trouve
que beaucoup de gens sont perdus en vrai
et ça rend pas les gens
heureux et tout ça pour moi n'est pas du
tout l'ennemi de l'audace
créatrice là aussi je crois pardon de le
Red dire comme ça parce qu'on m'en a
beaucoup targué à en même temps c'est
pas une
ambiguïté je le disais tout à l'heure
c'est une double
radicalité moi je crois au patrimoine ça
peut vous sembler vieux jeu et à la
création et parfois on peut marier l'un
et l'autre et donc la politique que je
vous ai décrite c'est vrai elle remet
parfois de l'ordre républicain une forme
d'autorité parce que je pense qu'on en a
besoin elle remet de l'éducation au cœur
et l'éducation c'est tout à la fois la
transmission de
savoir d'un héritage de
et c'est aussi la confiance qu'on vous
donne qui va ensuite vous permettre de
créer et de vous de vous en émanciper de
vous comporter
librement mais je crois que ce faisant
c'est c'est ça vraiment qui vous permet
d'avoir aussi l'esprit
critique l'absence de règles la liberté
absolue c'est pas la véritable liberté
il n'y a de liberté que si des
contraintes existent il n'y a de liberté
que si des limites à cell-ci existent il
n'y a de véritable émancipation que si
un ordre
existe je crois par ailleurs que les
réformes que je porte sont aussi celles
d'une société de progrès ce qu'on a fait
avec les lois bioéthiques la PMA pour
tout au premier quinquena ce qu'on va
faire avec la constitutionnalisation de
l'IVG ou avec la fin de Villa sont des
lois de progrès qui montr que c'est une
société qui change qu'on accompagne mais
je crois très profondément
que le progrès va aussi avec une forme
d'ordre républicain et si l'ordre n'est
pas républicain le le risque que nous
courons c'est parce que nos compatriotes
chercheront des repères c'est que cet
ordre devienne
réactionnaire regardez ce qui se passe
dans beaucoup de pays en Europe en
particulier face à des sociétés qui
doutent vous avez des dirigeants qui
transforment leur histoire qui disent
pas ce que je dis sur l'instruction
civique ou l'histoire qui la
réinventent qui ont une histoire
glorieuse moi je suis pour enseigner
l'histoire tout entière de la République
universaliste ce serait vieux jeu si je
vous disais je vais réécrire l'histoire
j'espère que je me fais comprendre c'est
c'est ça et donc je pense oui qu'il faut
qu'il faut les deux en même temps
résolument et complètement et que c'est
comme ça qu'on pourra créer je le crois
une jeunesse mais aussi une
nation qui se connaît
elle-même qui se respecte qui sait d'où
elle vient et qui aura une vraie
ambition pour où elle va et avec des
espaces de contestation des libertés
individuelles des voies de progrès des
débats comme nous aimons en avoir sur
tous les sujets possibles
voilà monsieur le
Président bonjour Claire gâtinois du
journal Le Monde monsieur le Président
vous défendez la justice sociale et la
lutte contre l'assignation à résidence
mais depuis l'adoption du projet de loi
immigration certains enfants d'immigrés
non européens seront précarisé puisque
leurs parents devront attendre un délai
pour toucher certaines prestations
sociales contrairement au français sur
la base du principe de la préférence
nationale que défend aussi l'extrême
droite comment tout là se tient quel est
la cohérence de cette action merci
d'abord je me garderaai bien de dire
comme vous venez de le faire que ça
existe la loi a était votée elle est
soumise au Conseil constitutionnel et
j'aurai ensuite à promulguer un texte
qui sera corrigé de ces censures
éventuelles aujourd'hui ce que vous
décrivez n'est pas ensuite je me garde
bien aussi de faire des raccourcis avec
le rassemblement national sur ce que en
reprenant ces TER vous appelez la
préférence nationale mais l'accès à des
prestations dans notre pays il est déjà
conditionné à des
durées il est déjà conditionné à des
durées aujourd'hui il faut 5 ans pour
toucher le RSA ou la prime
d'activité et il y a beaucoup d'autres
prestations contributiv ou non
contributif où il y a des délais faut
que tout ça se fasse dans les règles
est-ce que c'était un souhait de la
majorité du gouvernement la réponse est
non
est-ce que c'était poussé par des
oppositions la réponse est oui est-ce
que ça a été mis dans la balance d'un
compromis qu'il fallait dans une
majorité relative pour avancer oui
est-ce que je pense qu'il fallait avoir
un accord sur ce texte oui on va
attendre d'abord qu'il soit soumis au
contrôle constitutionnel on en parlera
après mais ce que vous dites est faux
dans les termes aujourd'hui dans notre
pays il y a des
délais de résidence parfois de travail
pour avoir accès à des prestations y
compris au quotidien et est-ce que c'est
c'est injuste ma réponse et non c'est
pas toujours aberrant parce que vous ne
pouvez pas avoir une démocratie avec un
modèle social aussi généreux que le
nôtre qui ne conditionne pas à certaines
règles l'accès aux prestations parce que
sinon vous n'aurez plus de consensus
social parce que sinon les gens vous
diront pour certaines prestations ben
moi je suis citoyen français je respecte
toutes les règles parfois moi j'ai
travaillé je les finance et donc
quionque rentre sur le sol il a accès ça
marche pas reconnaîtrez avec moi donc là
aussi il faut savoir faire les choses de
manière très méthodique loin des
passions ce que défend le rassemblement
national c'est pas ça il défend la
déscolarisation des ENF plutôt l'école
le non accès à l'école de manière
systématique pour les enfants de
personnes en situation irrégulière on le
fait pas on continue de scolariser les
enfants et c'est une fierté de la
République il défend des contraintes en
matière de logement on na jamais au
moment où je vous parle oui je défends
la justice sociale je vais vous dire il
fait froid en ce moment l'hébergement
d'urgence
on est passé à 200000 places aujourd'hui
quand j'ai été élu on était à 93000
places si c'est pas de la justice 60 %
de cet effort il est fait pour des
familles et des femmes et des hommes qui
sont en attente de régularisation ou en
situation irrégulière donc on va
continuer de se battre mais on va le
faire avec des règles et Front national
comme je préfère continuer à l'appeler
il propose quoi la préférence sur des
emplois à des Français et des règles
plus simples pour licencier des
étrangers est-ce que c'est ce qu'on fait
non donc si on confond tout après on me
les banalise après on dit tout est un
tout tout se vaut non
oui je revendique de lutter contre
l'immigration clandestine sur notre
territoire c'est une nécessité oui je
revendique de pouvoir démler les réseaux
de passeur oui je revendique de pouvoir
simplifier les règles pour qu'on puisse
plus vite instruire les dossier protéger
ceux qui ont être là parce qu'ils sont
chercheurs étudiants combattants pour la
liberté mais aussi pouvoir reconduire
vers leur pays ceux qui sont rentrés par
des voies illégales et qui n'ont pas
resté sur notre sol ça c'est pas être du
rassemblement national parce que si vous
laissez ça au rassemblement national je
peux vous dire là vous lui pavrez la
route bonsoir monsieur le Président
Adrien bec France Info on a assez peu
finalement parlé de de démocratie des
sujet de renouveau démocratique ce soir
il y a toujours ce sujet qui revient de
la démocratie directe et de depuis votre
arrivée au pouvoir depuis 2017 vous
n'avez pas utilisé l'outil
constitutionnel du référendum vous
l'avez souvent évoqué encore au l'été
dernier chez nos confrères du point vous
aviez dit je compte bien l'utiliser on
est toujours sans nouvelle de de cette
question de de référendum donc
finalement alors que cela fera 20 ans
l'année prochaine qu'aucun référendum
n'a été pratiqué en France est-ce que
vous allez faire un référendum ou est-ce
que vous avez c'est ce que suggéreront
certains peur peut-être de de cette
démocratie directe et par ailleurs
est-ce qu'il il vous serait possible ou
est-ce que vous
jugeriez possible et pertinent de faire
un référendum avec peut-être plusieurs
questions c'est ce que certains évoquent
je vous remercie merci pour votre
question vous avez raison j'évoqué
rapidement au début que les institutions
ne seraient pas traité mais le renouveau
de la vie démocratique est importante on
a beaucoup
innové un grand débat nit pas de
précédent des conventions citoyennes qui
ont permis une loi climat et maintenant
la préparation de la loi pour la fin de
vie une réforme conseil économique
social environnemental qu' l'
complètement transformé on a fait
d'ailleurs la chambre de ces conventions
citoyennes est d'une forme de
consultation nouvelle on a beaucoup
modernisé à cet égard notre
démocratie et on a eu un débat dans le
format dit de Saint-Denis j'ai rassemblé
les forces politiques sur la base d'une
proposition qui était fait d'élargir le
champ du référendum j'ai tôt vu à la
consultation des forces politiques qui
avait pas de consensus pour faire
cheminer cette proposition et l'ouvrir à
des questions sociétales comme je
l'avais moi-même proposé en 2019 la
question c'est c'est maintenant l'usage
du référendum tel qu'il est prévu par
notre Constitution dans le champ de
l'article 11 oui je le ferai j'ai pas
d'annonce aujourd'hui sur le
sujet sinon je l'aurais faite mais je
pense que c'est une bonne chose et
j'aurais même souhaité pour tout vous
dire l'ouvrir aux questions sociétales
mais le consensus n'est pas là pour le
faire monsieur le Président Francesco
Fanti pour l'agence France press vous
avez fait de l'école la mer desb
et vous avez encore annoncé plusieurs
mesures ce soir et plusieurs chantiers
peuvent-ils être menés à bien par la
nouvelle ministre de l'Éducation Amélie
ou casterra qui est affaibli d'entrée de
jeu par une intense polémique à laquelle
il a été fait référence et a-t-elle
votre confiance pour continuer dans ses
fonctions merci merci pour votre
question oui
d'abord la ministre a fait un choix pour
ses
enfants ce sont des choix individuels
personnels je le disais faut les
respecter je trouve que c'est bien et je
pense que tous nos compatriotes
d'ailleurs iront dans sensé et je pense
que ça fait partie de la vie intime
familiale que beaucoup d'ailleurs qui
sont ind parfois le font pour leurs
propres enfants eux même et j'ai pas
rentré là-dedans moi je le respecte et
je l'ai dit moi j'aiété dans les deux
écoles je relisais d'ailleurs un texte
de Jean jores qui avait eu à subir en
1901 une polémique absolument terrible
parce qu'il avait fait faire la
communion à sa fille et il avait avec
beaucoup d'humilité dit je tranche pas
mieux qu'un autre ces débats qui sont de
chaque citoyen individuel et personnel
ensuite la ministre a eu un propos
public qui a été maladroit elle s'en est
excusé elle a bien fait je vais vous
dire j'ai plutôt de l'indulgence parce
qu'il m'est arrivé d'avoir des propos au
tout début de mes responsabilité
politique qui avait blessé tout
particulièrement des femmes dans une
entreprise du Grand Ouest et et quand on
blesse surtout sans s'en rendre compte
on a raison de s'excuser moi je pense
que il y a pas d'école qui tienent si on
n pas tous nos enseignants avec nous
font un travail remarquable et j'ai
l'occasion de le dire ils travaillent
d'arrachepied pour préparer leur cours
corriger leur copier devant les élèves
continuer d'innover et donc la ministre
réussira sa tâche avec les enseignants
après elle a soulevé un sujet qui est un
sujet véritable votre collègue l'a
rappelé et ce sera une des priorités
qu'elle aura conduit à conduire dans le
droitfil de ce que le premier ministre
avait encore à faire il y a quelques
semaines
bonsoir monsieur le président Frédéric
Aziza de Radio J que pouvez-vous nous
dire de l'opération d'acheminement des
médicaments vers les otages du Hamas
quel a été votre rôle et celui de de la
France et puis avez-vous des nouvelles
des trois outages français enfin vous
avez annoncé qu'un hommage national
serait rendu aux 41 victimes françaises
des massacres du ramas du 7 octobre
êtes-vous en mesure de nous en préciser
la date et aussi la forme que pourrait
prendre cet
hommage merci pour votre question vous
avez d'abord raison de rappeler que la
France a perdu 41 de ses enfants dans
les attaques terroristes du 7 octobre
dernier ce qui fait de ces
attaques l'acte terroriste plus
meurtrier DEP
punis le 7 février
prochain au monument pour les victimes
du terrorisme jardin des Invalides je
rendrai hommage à ces victimes au côté
de leurs proches de leurs famille et de
tous ceux qui voudront nous y rejoindre
ce sera 4 mois jour pour jour après
l'attaque
terroriste nous avons libéré quatre
otages nous avons encore trois otages
qui sont détenus et nous nous battons
pied à
pied avec les autorités israéliennes
avec le Qatar qui a un rôle décisif en
la matière avec
aussi plusieurs autres collègues pour
les libérer je ne veux ici faire aucune
annonce parce que ces matières sont
toujours délicates et je pense aussi aux
familles
mais nous nous battons nous ne lâcherons
rien et j'espère que les prochains jours
prochaines semaines nous
permettront d'obtenir leur libération en
tout cas nous voulons tous les ramener
chez nous
ensuite cette attaque terroriste a
déclenché une réaction d'Israël et des
Bombard SVE depuis maintenant plus de
jours particulier sur la bande de
Gaza sur ce sujet reviendrai si d'autres
questions sont posé la
France approche qui depuis le début a
été de condamner de manière
intraitableattaque terroriste d'avoir au
fond une réponse qui est la paix la
sécurité pour tous lutter contre le
terrorisme l'approche humanitaire ce qui
nous a conduit à des aides humanitaires
et à une demande de cesser le feu et la
solution politique des deux états
pour ce qui est de l'humanitaire qui est
votre question nous avons mené une
action résolue et je dois le dire
inédite pour un pays
occidental depuis le début d'abord en
déployant des militaires et tout des
moyens militaires et tout
particulièrement le dixmud qui restera
jusqu'à la fin du mois et qui a déjà
permis de soigner plus de 1000 patients
enfants adultes avec un dévouement
extraordinaire des médecins qui sont
présents qui se sont relayés sur
celui-ci une coopération exemplaire avec
l'Égypte nous avons plus de 1000 tonnes
de fr de soutien d'aide compris
médicaments qui ont été
livrés et nous avons en effet ces
dernières semaines mis en place des
opérations très délicate pour livrer de
l'aide dans la bande de gazamê le 3
janvier dernier nous avons avec les
jordanien mener une opération pour
larguer justement des rations
alimentaires
sur la bande de Gaza et nous sommes en
train d'agir nous avons commencé à agir
avec le Qatar pour en effet délirer des
médicaments dans la bande de Gaza et
nous continuerons de le faire avec tous
les partenaires de la région qui nous
aident pour cette action humanitaire qui
a beaucoup mobiliser à la fois nos
militaires nos diplomates et sur lesquel
nous travaillons aussi avec beaucoup
d'associations et d'ONG qui sont
absolument exemplaire dans cette
action
Ava jamidi magazine L bonsoir monsieur
le Président une dernière question si
vous le permettez pour clore la séquence
de de politique intérieure vous avez
implicitement évoqué le rôle des femmes
dans le cadre du réarmement
démographique que vous appelez de vos
vœux depuis 2017 l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes fait partie des
grandes cause de votre quinquena c'est
un axe fort de votre politique
d'ailleurs la parité est atteinte dans
le gouvernement de votre premier
ministre mais pourquoi n'y a-t-il aucune
femme à la tête d'un d'un ministère
égalien 2uxè question la la révolution
Mitou a permis d'aider à une prise de
conscience contre les attitudes
prédatrices de certains hommes une
révolution initiée par les médias qui
sont fait ni pour se substituer à la
justice mais pour dénoncer des des
agissements
répréhensibles ces attitudes odieuses
comme celle mise à jour par les images
de nos confrères de complément d'enquête
sur Gérard de pardieu est-ce que vous
comprenez monsieur le Président les mois
provoqués par vos propos sur la fierté
que vous inspire une telle personnalité
est-ce que la lutte contre les violences
sexuelles et sexistes reste une priorité
de votre mandat merci beaucoup merci de
m'offrir là
l'opportunité de clarifier ce sujet
essentiel bon d'abord le gouvernement
est paritaire vous l'avez dit et il sera
complété ensuite et continuera d'être
paritaire et il y a eu depuis le début
de mes responsabilité des moments où il
y avait plus de femmes qui étaient dans
le carré régalien un d'autres moment où
c'était à des fonctions qui sont clé
quand j'ai martelé
que la santé l'école et l'enseignement
supérieur étaient au cœur de mes
priorités comme politique
publique je constate que vous avez une
femme ministre de la Santé du travail et
des solidarités une femme ministre de
l'éducation nationale etio une femme
ministre de l'Enseignement supérieur et
de la Recherche voilà et c'est aussi une
forme de nouveau régalien je
l'assume donc n'y voyez pas là malice ou
retrait bien au contraire il y a eu
beaucoup de polémiqu ces dernières
semaines ça ne m'a pas échappé je me
permettrai toutefois de
dire que je me souvient d'octobre
2016 c'était la conclusion de ce qu'on
avait appelé la grande marche j'étais
alors pas encore candidat simplement
ministre
démissionnaire c'était le début d'une
longue série de commentaires politiques
où l'on me disait que je n'avais pas de
programme ça a duré très
longtemps et faisant le contrendu de
cette grande marche je disais la
première préoccupation ce sont les
violences faites aux femmes en
particulier dans les transports j'ai pas
attendu tout j'ai eu le regard sceptique
de beaucoup de gens et beaucoup de
commentateurs
aujourd'hui disant c'est vraiment un
drôle lui c'est ça sa
priorité les archives sont là pour le
montrer allez aussi les chercher c moi
j'assume Pasir du Mitou pour dire
l'égalité femm hommes et les violences
faites aux femmes c'est un problème
inadmissible et parfois un continent
caché et j'assume en effet depuis 6 ans
et demi d'avoir agi avec beaucoup de
force et je vais vous dire je n'ai aucun
regret d'avoir défendu la présomption
d'innocence pour une personnalité
publque un artiste en l'espèce comme je
l'ai fait pour des responsables
politiques si j'ai un regret à ce
moment-là c'est de ne pas avoir assez
dit combien la parole des femmes qui
sont victimes de ces violences est
importante et combien ce combat est
essentiel pour moi et nous continu
l'action et on a agi on a multiplié
comme jamais les crédits aux
associations qui qui se développent sur
le terrain on a multiplié par 2 et demi
les ordonnances de protection on a
développé plus de 1000 bracelets qui
sont offerts et qui protège chaque jour
des femmes on a facilité le moyen de
dénoncer les conjoints ou mari
violents on a formé tous nos policiers
nos gendarmes qui étaient en école au
total 140000 d'entre eux sont formés
pour prendre les plaintes ce qui était
du tout le cas avant on a développé ces
téléphones grave danger qui sont si
importants les places d'hébergement sont
passé de 5000 à 10000 de 5000 à 10000 le
391 si important pour toutes les femmes
qui sont victimes de ces violences a eu
des moyens accrus comme jamais et passé
7 jours sur 7 et 24 he sur 24 et encore
et encore je pourrais
continuer depuis le premier jour et même
avant comme je le rappelais le sujet des
violences faites aux femmes est une
priorité nous continuerons de nous
battre contre ce phénomène de société il
y a eu des tas de milieux où en effet
l'omerta a
prévalu et je me félicite que la parole
se libère et je souhaite qu'elle puisse
se libérer au maximum mais je pense que
notre rôle c'est de permettre son cadre
c'est que la justice puisse faire son
travail c'est qu'on protège les femmes
qui sont menacées mais que là aussi on
ne le fasse pas en oubliant les
principes constitutionnels qui sont les
nôtres dans la présomption d'innocence
monsieur le Président bonsoir Ulis doset
de BFM TV vous nous avez dit au début de
votre conférence de presse la France est
menacée et vous avez confié à vos
ministres lors de la première réunion du
Conseil la mission de tout faire pour
éviter l'effacement de la France alors
quelle est la principale menace pour la
France aujourd'hui dans le monde est-ce
que c'est un risque de guerre est-ce que
c'est un risque de guerre en Europe si
Poutine allait plus loin que l'Ukraine
par exemple est-ce que c'est un risque
de guerre au Proche Orient est-ce qu'il
y a effectivement un risque d'effacement
de la France et comment y faire face et
puis un exemple concret Trump pourrait
revenir à la Maison Blanche est-ce que
c'est une menace est-ce que Donald Trump
est une menace pour l'Europe la France
l'Alliance atlantique pour la stabilité
du monde et est-ce que vous vous y
préparez et comment merci d'abord je
crois pas du tout qu'il y a un risque
d'effacement pour notre pays pas
utiliser ce terme pour les ministres et
je F pas à la réalité je suis pas dans
le pessimisme la réalité c'est que nous
avons un monde qui est
déréglé et ça il faut le constater il se
dérègle pourquoi d'abord parce qu'il y a
une tension sinino-américaine qui est
structurante et donc nous avons un
risque d'être bousculé nous européens
c'est pourquoi je veux une Europe plus
forte parce que c'est pas la France
seule qui pourra résister à cette
tension il faut une Europe plus
souveraine
c'est-à-dire qui assume d'avoir un allié
les États-Unis d'Amérique mais qui ne
veut pas en
dépendre et donc nous nous devons être
en quelque sorte le 3è pôle de stabilité
qui aura à vivre avec peut-être des
tensions qui vont monter mais ne pas
être déstabilisé pareil et rester dans
des équilibres du monde c'est toujours
la voie sur laquelle j'ai inscrit la
France qui correspond d'ailleurs à son
histoire diplomatique parler à tout le
monde avoir des alliés chercher des
alliances être une puissance qui
construit des équilibres et des
solutions nouvelles et qui en
particulier évite cette grande division
du Nord face au sud qui serait
terrible mais cette tension est
structurante là deuxième chose c'est que
vous avez des membres du Conseil de
sécurité qui ont décidé de ne plus
respecter la Charte des Nations Unies la
Russie et ça c'est un fait nouveau des
10 dernières années il a commencé en
février 2014 ça change tout et ça fait
dysfonctionner l'ordre international que
nous connaissions et donc nous devons
rebattir des règles adoc c'est ce que la
France d'ailleurs cherche à faire avec
le partenariat justement et le pacte de
Paris pour les peuples et la planète
c'està-dire trouver des réponses sur ces
grands biens communs avec les pays du
Sud bousculer lies pour éviter justement
cette grande
division pour ça il faut une diplomatie
forte qui parle à tout le monde qui
refuse l'alignement
systématique il faut une économie forte
française et européenne qui ne dépend
pas financièrement technologiquement
académiquement sur telle ou telle
solution ni de la Chine ni des
États-Unis il faut une armée forte et un
modèle complet d'armée qu'on renforce
sur le plan des capacités qui innove et
qui robuste c'est notre cas et avec les
deux lois de programmation militaire qui
auront doublé le budget de nos armées ce
sera conforté et il faut une Europe
forte qui refuse la logique de bloc et
qui peut nous permettre en quelqu sorte
de faire face à des déséquilibres
nouveaux le plus grand risque à mes yeux
est la guerre d'agression russe en
Ukraine nous ne pouvons pas laisser la
Russie gagner et nous ne devons pas le
faire car alors la sécurité même de
l'Europe et de tout le voisinage russe
serait remise en cause laisser la Russie
gagné c'est au fond acceptter que les
règles de l'ordre
international tes que nous les avons
définis peuvent ne plus être
respectés pour nos amis baltes polonais
roumains c'est une vie impossible je
n'oublie pas la Moldavie et aussi les
pays du Caucase et donc nous devons tout
faire c'est le principal sujet à mes
yeux de mobilisation et sur lequel le
risque est là
ensuite les électeurs américains auront
à se décider en fin d'année j'ai
toujours la même philosophie je prends
les dirigeants que les peuples me
donnent et j'engage au service de la
France et de ses intérêts le dialogue
avec quiconque j'ai eu à faire avec le
président Trump pendant tout son mandat
durant premier
quinen nous avons eu des résultats nous
avons pu faire ensemble des choses
importantes l'opération Hamilton le 13
avril 2018 qui a fait respecter notre
ligne rouge face au président
Poutine des opérations concrètes un
réengagement sur plusieurs sujet nous
avons eu des
échecs le
climat certaines
taxations mais plus largement je pense
qu'il ne faut pas s'intéresser aux
personnes il faut avoir la lucidité de
voir que les États-Unis d'Amérique sont
un grand allié dont nous célébrerons le
courage en particulier lors des
débarquements de Normandie en juin
prochain il partage nos valeurs mais
c'est une démocratie qui traverse aussi
une crise dont la priorité première est
elle-même et dont la deuxème priorité la
question
chinoise et donc nous devons tous
européens être lucides sur cela c'est
aussi pour ça que je veux une Europe
plus forte qui sche se protéger
elle-même et qui ne dépendent pas des
autres c'est ça comme c'est la manière
dont je je prépare l'élection
américaine quel que soit son
résultat
merci bonsoir monsieur le Président
Sophie
pconomist vendredi dernier à Kiev le
Royaume-Uni a signé un avec l'Ukraine un
accord bilatéral de garantie de sécurité
conformément aux engagements pris lors
du sommet G7 Vilnius où on est la France
sur ce sujet et comment est-ce que la
France va contribuer dans dans les
médias un
sursaut en matière d'aide militaire et
stratégique à l'Ukraine face à
l'agression russe merci merci beaucoup
nous travaillons très étroitement avec
tous nos partenaires européens et en
particulier nos partenaires britanniques
nous sommes en train de finaliser un
accord de ce type qui sera signé dans
les prochaines
semaines bilat permettant en effet des
éléments de
garantie nous allons procéder à des
livraisons nouvelles une quarantaine de
missilees scalp et plusieurs centaines
de bombes attendu par nos amis
Ukrainiens nous avons aussi développé
des productions dans ce casadre de
l'économie de guerre qui vont permettre
de fournir beaucoup plus de matériel à
nos partenaires Ukrainiens en
particulier des Césars qui sont attendus
et nécessaires et donc nous allons au
fond continuer d'aider l'Ukraine dans
ses
besoins de
formation pour tenir sur le front et
pour défendre son ciel avec les
livraisons que j'aiévoqué avec les
accords que nous finaliserons j'irai
moi-même en février en Ukraine
j'annoncerai la finalisation de ces
textes les livraisons de munition que
j'évoque là seront commencés et à chaque
fois que nous nous annonçons nous
faisons quasiment en temps réel comme
vous le savez
et nous aurons très clairement nous
Français et nous Européens à prendre des
décisions nouvelles dans les semaines et
les mois qui
viennent précisément pour ne pas laisser
la Russie
gagner bonjour monsieur le Président
Simon Lebaron pour France interre la
situation humanitaire est catastrophique
à Gaza des dizaines de milliers de morts
c'est difficile de savoir combien
exactement 25000 à peu près selon le
ministère de la Santé du Hamas est-ce
que vous estimez on faire assez pour
éviter cette situation humanitaire qui
est déjà catastrophique d'abord vous
avez raison merci de me permettre de
revenir sur sur ce sujet ayant évoqué
l'attaque terroriste du Hamas contre
Israël toutes les vies se valent et nous
sommes bouleversés par aujourd'hui les
vies qui sont touchées à Gaza et qui
sont en quelque sorte la conséquence de
cette attaque terroriste du Hamas et la
responsabilité est immense de ce groupe
terroriste qui a déclenché cette
riposte je l'ai dit nous menons des
opérations
humanitaires
multiples avec nos militaires avec nos
diplomates avec nos largages fra
médicaments vivre en périphérie et sur
la bande de Gaza mais la priorité est le
cesser le feu j'ai quasiment chaque
semaine le Premier ministre netaniahou
en
ligne nous réitérons cela avec
d'ailleurs plusieurs puissances de la
région les États-Unis d'Amérique l'ont
également fait nous soutiennent dans
cette approche c'est une priorité
pourquoi parce que après plus de 100
jours ce sont maintenant des opérations
ciblées qui doivent être conduite et il
faut
concilier la défense d'Israël et la
poursuite des terroristes avec la
préservation du droit
humanitaire et je le dis parce que c'est
aussi l'intérêt l'intérêt sur le plan de
la sécurité à long terme d'Israël et que
poursuivre aujourd'hui les opérations
telles qu'elles sont conduites c'est
prendre un risque pris dans la durée
comptetenue de ce que cela fait nêre
dans toute la région pour la sécurité
d'Israël même donc nous allons
poursuivre les initiatives diplomatiques
résolution discussion pour appeler à un
cesser le feu et je vaisi poursuivre le
contact bilatéral pour essayer de
l'obtenir de manière très concrète c'est
ça maintenant la priorité car on sait
c'est ce qui permettra d'aller au cont
des populations de les protéger et tout
ça est lié à quoi à une stratégie
odieuse qui est la stratégie du pire
celle utilisée par le Hamas qui met ses
réserves d'armes et ses centres de
décision sous les écoles caché dans les
hôpitaux qui utilise comme bouclier une
partie de la population civile mais au
point au moment où nous en sommes et la
France dit cela depuis plusieurs
semaines nous devons cesser ces attaques
qui sont par trop indifférencié et nous
devons protéger les populations civiles
c'est un devoir humanitaire parce qu'il
peut pas y avoir de standards et que
toutes les vies se valent donc on va
poursuivre le travail et je peux pas
vous dire qu'on est réussi aujourd'hui
et que je m'en considère comme satisfait
je vois avec la même douleur que vous
les scènes que nous voyons et je sais
aussi ce que cela produit dans chez
beaucoup de nos compatriotes et dans
beaucoup de pays de la région et je le
disais nous nous battons pour lutter
contre les terroristes nous nous battons
pour le cesser le feu et pour la réponse
humanitaire et nous nous battons pour
qu'il y ait une vraie réponse dans la
durée à l'aspiration légitime du peuple
palestinien pour avoir un état parce que
c'est ça qui apportera la sécurité et la
stabilité dans la
durée et je ne voudrais pas que ce qui
est en train de se passer compromette la
possibilité d'une solution
politique euh bonsoir monsieur le
Président de la République Husain knber
la chaîne Alarabia la France continue de
passer des messages euh à toutes les
parties concernées par la résolution
1701 euh la situation est très tendue
entre le Liban et Israël à la frontière
euh est-ce que ces parties à qui vous
passez ces messages ont été réceptives
et à ce que l'embrasement régional est
toujours évitable d'après vous avec tout
ce qui se passe en mer Rouge
merci merci à vous vous avez évoqué la
mer Rouge la France est active elle l'
d'ailleurs depuis les premiers jours
et elle l' historiquement toutes ces
dernières années pour
œuvrer à la liberté de circulation
maritime en mer rouge comme dans les
axes principaux essentiels au au
commerce
mondial à ce titre nous avons une
approche comme vous le savez qui est
défensive et nous assumons le cadre de
cette action pour ce qui est des
résolution du Conseil de sécurité et au
fond de la frontière avec le Liban qui
est le fond de votre question
nous avons une très grande vigilance
depuis le début pour éviter que
l'embrasement ne soit régional que le
hzbollah ne se joigne au conflit et ne
menace la sécurité d'Israël et surtout
que le conflit ne s'étende au Liban la
France est attachée à la paix à la
stabilité au Liban et donc en effet nous
avons depuis le début passé des messages
directs et indirects à l'ensemble des
forces politiques
libanaises à l'ensemble des forces
militaires compris terroriste
et nous avons tout fait pour éviter
l'escalade nous avons fait plusieurs
propositions ces dernières semaines en
lien avec les États-Unis d'Amérique aux
Israéliens pour justement essayer
d'avancer sur ce sujet notre volonté est
en effet que les résolutions soi
strictement respecté qu'en
particulier les frappes qui ont eu lieu
encore ces dernières semaines c que les
incursions qu'il a pu avoir soi
interrompu mais que des deux côtés la
résolution soit respectée et c'est
indispensable comme vous le savez la
France est aussi engagée dans le cadre
de la finule et ce depuis maintenant des
décennies et donc nous sommes vigilants
aussi avec les Nations unies pour que le
mandat soit tenu que les moyens soient
engagés et que les équilibres soient
maintenus nous surveillons avec beaucoup
de vigilance la situation et au fond
notre message à toutes les parties est
d'éviter tout escalade elles ne sont
l'intérêt de personne
s monsieur le Président nous arrivons au
terme de cet échange nous allons devoir
cl dernière
question là j'ai pas
réussi je bien prendre une dernière
question puisquon m'a dit qu'il fallait
après rendre l'antenne comme dit bonsoir
monsieur le Président c'est la pour TF1
LCI en quelques mots en quelques mots
vous avez beaucoup parlé de réarmement
mais pas encore de réarmement militaire
la loi de programmation militaire nous
nous prémunitelle pardon de toutes les
menaces la France n'aurait-elle pas
intérêt aujourd'hui à investir dans la
lutte contre les outil normalement
notamment pardon en mer Rouge est-ce
qu'ils sont une menace aujourd'hui pour
nous merci d'avance la France a décidé
de ne pas se joindre à une coalition qui
a cherché qui a conduit des frappes
préventiv contre les outil sur leur sol
pourquoi précisément parce que nous
avons une posture qui cherche à éviter
tout escalade mais nous sommes présents
pour préserver la liberté de navigation
et d'ailleurs nous avons interrompu
missiles et drones qui allent
frapper des navires norvégiens et donc
nous agissons pour protéger nos propres
équipements et les équipements de nos
alliés donc nous agissons mais le cadre
c'est pas un sujet militaire c'est un
sujet diplomatique et pourquoi nous le
faisons parce que nous sommes vigilants
et attentifs aux équilibres de la région
et au fait qu'il ne doit pas y avoir des
escalade
ensuite je peux vous confirmer que vous
avez une armée dont vous pouvez être
fier nous avons un modèle d'armée
complet qui n'a pas subi les
affaiblissements que plusieurs autres
armées européennes avaient pu faire
avaient pu avoir et que nous avons
surtout renforcé très fortement je le
disais par une première loi de
programmation militaire qui a permis de
consolider beaucoup de choses et à
hauteur d'homme comme je l'ai dit pour
avoir davantage d'engager les fidéliser
avoir des familles qui sont mieux
accompagnés et donc les femmes et les
hommes qui sont d'abord la force de nos
armées leur commandement mais également
préserver notre dissuasion nucléaire qui
est une force de l'armée française et
avoir aussi un réengagement dans toutes
nos capacités en volume comme en
innovation et c'est ce que nous allons
poursuivre avec cette deè cette deè loi
de programmation militaire qui a fait
l'objet d'un travail inédit conduit par
nos armées sous l'autorité du ministre
et du chef d'état-major des armées qui a
permis d'abord de voir quels étaient les
nouveaux risques qui a consolidé notre
modèle d'armée historique d'aller plus
vite sur les capacités dont nous avions
besoin de consolider encore une fois
notre nucléaire mais aussi d'aller sur
les risques
cyber exoatmosphérique et donc le
spatial et maritime qui sont les grands
risques stratégiques du 21e siècle et
que les conflits que nous sommes en
train d'avoir ne doivent pas nous faire
oublier donc je pense pouvoir vous dire
en conscience que nous sommes équipés
nous sommes armés et nous serons encore
davantage demain mais que nous n'avons
pas de faiblesse à cet égard et que qui
plus est ce qui fait le modèle de la
France y compris dans les décisions
d'engagement qui sont les nôtres est une
force car nous savons engager vite quand
la situation devient difficile nous
l'avons encore montrer quelle est
l'armée qui s'est engagé en quelques
jours comme nous l'avons fait en
déployant nos forces en Roumanie
quelques jours à peine après le début de
la guerre en 2022 en Ukraine c'est une
force maintenant nous devons la
compléter
en développant une défense européenne
davantage de programmes communs
davantage d'investissement standardiser
nos grand programmes industriel européen
et en ayant une culture
militaire plus intime avec nos
partenaires c'est tout le sens de
l'initiative européenne d'intervention
que j'avais lancé à la Sorbon dans
laquelle vous avez maintenant une
dizaine d'États européens et nous avons
AG par laquelle nous avons agir ensemble
en Afrique et ailleurs et ce que nous
allons continuer de faire donc oui nous
Français européen nous sommes solides
nous serons encore plus deain et nous
serons vigilants à pousser nos alliés et
nos partenaires européens à le faire et
à l'être voilà mesdames et messieurs
merci pour vos questions vos attentions
m'a dit qu'il fallait que j'essaie de
tenir en 2 he et qu et donc j'espère
avoir pu répondre aux questions qui se
posaient mais je vous rassure vous me
reverrez bientôt pour répondre aux
autres merci à tous et toutes et encore
tous mes
vœux vous me disiez donc que Macron
avait fait du Macron pendant ce discours
oui là c'est ça et et voyez le la
conférence de presse était tellement
longue que les liens phonétiques ont dû
s'user au cours du temps concrètement
sur le sur la forme c'est une conférence
absolument classique et sur le fond on
attendait comme on le disait en
préambule de cette de cette conférence
de presse on attendait des grandes
annonces certainement que beaucoup de
Français sont restés sur leur fin
beaucoup de sujets déjà abordés comme le
service national universel comme les
différentes mesures concernant
l'éducation nationale ont finalement été
à nouveau exposées par le président mais
il n'y a pas eu grand-chose sur d'autres
sujets sur le le le débat sur la
sécurité on a l'impression que c'est pas
forcément sa tasse de thé donc la loi
sur l'immigration finalement se suffit à
elle-même il n'y a pas il n'y a rien eu
sur ce sujet qui concerne au 2e rang
après le pouvoir d'achat les les
Français sur la question de la nation sa
conception de la nation et cetera on
reste un petit peu on reste un petit peu
sur sa fin la défense a vraiment été
abordée en fin de conférence de presse
grâce à une question mais dans le monde
tel qu'il est avec les tensions qu'il y
a il y a des il y a des questions sur le
budget de la défense sur les choses
comme ça qui semblent pas avoir été du
tout abordé la démocratie le
fonctionnement de la démocratie au
détour d'une question également la
question du référendum qui qui qui qui
est évidemment central dans notre pays
puisqu'il n'est pas pratiqué comme l'a
dit d'ailleurs un des un des confrères
journaliste depuis 20 ans bientôt he
2005 de triste mémoire pour certains et
bien toutes ces questionsl qui étaient
quand même assez disruptif comme dit le
président Macron n'ont pas été abordés
donc on est resté dans un une certaine
forme de classicisme le Président il a
manifestement pris plaisir est-ce qu'il
aura convaincu les Français qui l'ont
regardé c'est moins sûr alors je vous
poserai la question d'ailleurs puisque
c'est notre question en ce moment sur le
site du Figaro mais onendra la fin de ce
direct pour vous la poser il y a eu
quand même quelques annonces du côté du
réarmement civique par exemple il a
annoncé l'expérimentation de la tenue
unique dès l'année 2024 alors c'était
quelque chose qui était dans les tuyaux
là c'est annoncé en bé du forme on peut
dire
oui en fait on on on voit bien lors
cette conférence de presse que le
Emmanuel Macron est quelqu'un qui a de
la pétence pour les questions
économiques c'est son sujet de
prédilection et on le voit bien que
comme c'est une personnalité
incontestablement intelligente il compr
on a un peu l'impression qu'il court
après ces questions
justement tournant autour de la nation
de l'unité nationale il n'a pas
forcément de la pétence pour cela mais
il a compris qu'il y avait un enjeu là
donc il court toujours un petit peu
après après ces sujets il prend des
initiatives euh sa crédibilité dans le
domaine à mon avis devrait en faire
beaucoup plus pour que il devienne
vraiment audible dans ce domaine parce
qu'on a toujours l'impression qu'il a un
peu de retard par rapport en tout cas à
l'attente des concitoyens tels qu'on le
voit dans les les les les sondage hm hm
alors je j'invite nos internautes bien
sûr à à poser leurs questions dans le
chat il y a un mot il y a une tournure
de phrase qui est assez qui est qui est
revenu souvent il a parlé d'audace et
d'audace créatrice c'est quelque chose
qu'il voulu mettre en avant lors de
cette conférence de presse on dans
l'impression
oui c'est c'est typiquement du
vocabulaire d'Emmanuel Macron c'est
c'est c'est justement c'est pas très
surprenant depuis toujours il parle
d'audace de
disruptif de révolutionnaire vous savez
il a écrit ce livre donc c'était la
révolution hein et donc il il n'hésite
pas à justement il ne manque pas
d'audace dans son vocabulaire peut-être
que sur des sujets plus régaliens comme
la sécurité comme le contrôle de
l'immigration jusqu'à présent ce n'était
pas son ses sujets de prédilection il a
peut-être manqué l'audace on pourrait
aussi avoir de l'audace dans ce domaine
pas seulement par les l'évocation d'une
politique répressive mais prendre des
initiatives et c'est pas complètement sa
tasse de thé h il y a eu il y a eu sur
les sur les questions alors c'est c'est
une question d'actualité en plus puisque
c'est aujourd'hui qui qui est tombé le
le chiffre du nombre de naissanceces un
grand plan aussi euh il a annoncé la
création d'un congé de naissance euh ça
aussi c'est quelque chose qu' il veut
s'approprier euh pour faire la
différence par rapport aux d'autres
alors ce sujet-là n'est pas un sujet
franco-français le le sujet de la de la
natalité est un sujet qui préoccupe tous
les grands pays du monde partout aucun
pays du monde aujourd'hui n'a une
natalité suffisante euh il y a des cas
graves comme le Japon comme la la Corée
comme l'Allemagne la France jusqu'à
présent était épargnée comme l'a dit le
président euh c'est n plus le cas
aujourd'hui on était longtemps sur 1 2,1
et aujourd'hui on est à 1,7 donc il y a
un vrai sujet alors l'initiative du
président par rapport au congé parental
euh est peut-être intéressante dans ce
sens où euh pour rappeler l'historique
il y avait d'abord pas grand-chose puis
après il y a eu la possibilité d'un
congé pour les pour les mamans qui était
assez long et qui finalement crée pas
forcément une dynamique notamment par
rapport aux femmes parce Queen gros
c'était leure indiqué que elle se elle
se consacré à ça et évidemment pour les
les déroulements de carrière c'était
assez compliqué pour les personnes de de
sexe féminin et donc cette idée là de
d'un congé de sorte de congé de
parentalité équilibré paritaire
peut-être une piste intéressante en
terme sociétal pour que et bien ne
serait-ce que le président l'a dit par
ailleurs he il y a beaucoup de de de de
de jeunes délincant parce que le père
n'est plus là peut-être ça peut
permettre de responsabiliser un petit
peu les les pères dans leur rôle de
parents et c'est peut-être une
initiative qui fait partie effectivement
des des initiatives intéressantes qu'a
évoqué ce soir le président de la
République h beaucoup beaucoup de choses
qu'il a évoqué on en parlait en avant de
live des il fallait des sujets concrets
euh pu il avit par exemple les baisses
d'impôts il a affirmer la baisse des
impôts de 2 milliards d'euros pour les
classes moyennes en 2025 par exemple non
très bel affichage très bel effet euh
effectivement que c'est c'est cette
somme astronomique mais comment quoi sur
quoi sur voilà là on reste un petit peu
sur sa fin le président pourra rétorquer
que c'est au Premier ministre lors de sa
déclaration de politique générale dans
préciser les contours et les modalités
et ce en quoi il aurait une application
euh exact de euh nos institutions
puisque c'est le président qui définit
les enjeux qui a la vision et le Premier
ministre qui euh qui définit la feuille
de route pour aboutir à la réalisation
de ces enjeux HM oui parce que pendant
toute cette conférence de presse il a
souvent euh renvoyé au futur euh au au
futur discours de politique générale euh
de gabrielal qui devrait avoir lieu
normalement le 30 janvier euh en disant
voilà moi je moi je dis ça mais je
laisse le
gouvernement mettre en musique ce que je
lui demande de faire enfin c'est un peu
comme ça qu'on l'a compris non oui bah
comme on l'avait dit dans notre
préambule il y avait il y avait un
risque avec cette conférence de presse
du président quelques jours avant
quelques semaines avant la la
déclaration de politique générale de
Gabriel Atal de lui couper l'Hair sous
le pied et donc par ce cet arguci cette
méthode il a eu tendance à renvoyer au
gouvernement au Premier ministre et à
ses ministres la la la mise en musique
de sa politique sans quoi il s'inscrit
quand même dans la tradition de la 5e
République le président décide organise
voilà les les les la grande alchimie
politique du pays et puis c'est au
Premier ministre qui dirige le
gouvernement de mettre en musique h al
dans les commentaires on a ABA qui nous
dit peut-on parler de ce que le
président a pu dire sur l'éducation et
la santé qui m'a semblé les points
faibles de son discours il en a tout de
même pas mal parlé de l'éducation et de
la santé alors il a parlé de l'éducation
côté civique il a parlé de l'éducation
par exemple vis-à-vis vis-à-vis des
écrans et la santé il a il a parlé par
exemple des déserts médicaux de
l'hôpital de tout ce qui avait été fait
finalement pour pour l'hôpital qu'en
avez-vous penser lugra oui alors bon il
a quand même parlé de ses ces sujets euh
en fait sur l'éducation il y a quand
même des des des des parties entières
qui n'a pas abordé mais on peut pas non
plus tout aborder et les questions
dirigent aussi un peu le débat notamment
la formation des enseignants qui est un
problème absolument essentiel dans ce
pays la formation des des des
enseignants on voit bien que elle doit
s'adapter à notre temps on peut pas
former aujourd'hui un enseignant comme
on le le on le formait n guerre il y a
des enjeux extrêmement importants hein
sur des sujets comme la sécurité le
racisme la citoyenneté et cetera il n'a
pas n'est pas rentré dans dans
manifestement dans une volonté de
réformer ou
d'accompagner la formation des des
enseignants ceci dit il a quand même
parlé il a quand même souligner
l'importance de l'éducation dans la
formation des futurs citoyens il l'a
quand même clairement dit cela sur la
santé il est bien bien sûr revenu sur le
problème du des déserts médicaux alors
il est dans une approche assez libérale
et peu dirigiste hein mais qui qui
caractérise dans dans beaucoup de sujets
c'est-à-dire qu'il ne veut pas imposer
il veut susciter euh les Français qui
ont du mal à trouver un généraliste ou
un ORL euh euh maintenant pas seulement
en province mais aussi à Paris vont
rester certainement assez dubitatif par
rapport à cela le les l'explication que
le numérus closus il faut 10 ans depuis
2018 17 pour arriver à a remontter les
les effectifs est assez laborieux à voir
aussi qu'il a dit donc qu'il allait
vouloir mieux intégrer les médecins
étrangers moi qui a un petit peu
d'expérience je me rappelle que il y a
il y a il y a quelques 20 ans c'était
tout le combat de de des des autorités
publiques de ne pas justement faire en
sorte que quelqu'un qui avait été formé
en médecine à l'étranger euh subissent
le même sort qu'un étudiant qui avait
été formé en France et on en arrive à un
point où on a tellement un problème de
de médecin que bien on on préfère passer
sur la question qualitative qui peut se
poser dans certains cas pour essayer de
de grandir le nombre c'est un peu le
nombre contre la vérification des
réelles compétences bien que même si des
des des éléments des médecins étrangers
sont parfois excellents h il y a eu il y
a eu on va maintenant laisser un peu de
côté les la partie annon c'était la
partie une des questions ensuite il y a
eu la partie 2 plutôt politique il y a
eu un moment où le chef de l'État est
pas c énervé mais il il a on lui a posé
une question sur le rassemblement
national et on a et on l'a senti très
investi sur ce sur ce sujet en tout cas
il a voulu montrer qu'il était très
investi c'est à peu près le seul moment
d'ailleurs où il a parlé aussi
précisément d'une autre formation
politique
ouais il a il a il est quasiment passé
aux aveux ce soir de sa stratégie en en
nommant Gabriel Attal Premier ministre
il a avant tout nommé pour engager une
dynamique pour affaiblir le camp d'en
face et
Bardella directement et et c'est donc
effectivement un combat qui l'anime je
pense qu'il y a une sincérité derrière
derrière ce propos après la question qui
se pose c'est est-ce qu'il n'a pas
grillé sa meilleure cartouche en nommant
Gabriel est-ce qu'il aurait pas mieux
fallu aller un peu à Canosa au moment
des européennes pour puisqu'ils seront
de toute manière pas bonne pour le camp
présidentiel avec ou sans Atal pour
sortir cette carte plus plus forte après
les européennes et ensuite s'inscrire
dans une
dynamique de de 2027 ça c'est une vraie
question qu'est-ce qu'il va faire après
les européenne si l'écart continue
d'être aussi important entre Renaissance
et le rassemblement national après les
européennes c'est une vraie question
d'autant que vous l'avez vu gluxman a
passé les 10 points maintenant et en
train de mordre sur une partie de
l'électorat Renaissance qui semble ex
socialiste qui semble revenir à la
maison ce qui prouve bien que dans notre
pays les partis de traditionnels de
gouvernement ne sont pas encore morts
raphaë guusman qui conduira la liste PS
aux européennes il a été aussi question
des ministres d'Emmanuel Macron on a
parlé d' d'Amélie oua Castera
ministreéducation et on a aussi parlé
des nouveaux arrivantes en qui venait
plutôt du côté Sarkozi on va dire avec
Catherine Vautrin et rachidti
oui alors surtout Rachid adati
d'ailleurs la caméra s assez apesantie
sur elle c'est assez contrat cyclique
c'est-à-dire que Emmanuel Macron parle
toujours de de
renouvellement et a appelé Rachid hadti
avec l'argument que
entre en sous-jacant que Rashida Dati
saurait ouvrir les portes de la culture
au milieu populaire et cetera bien sûr
que Rashida Dati a a beaucoup d'énergie
mais on voit bien que le choix de Rachid
hadti repose avant tout sur le fait que
c'est une combattante qu' a voulu
muscler son gouvernement dans la
perspective des européennes aussi
d'ailleurs Catherine Vautrin aussi est
une combattante la question posée c'est
est-ce que Macron 2017 était une
personnalité qui souhaitait muscler avec
des combattants son gouvernement ou
est-ce qu'il annonçait pas plutôt une
démocratie apaisée avec des gens qui
étaient avant tout revêtu de compétences
alors je je salue ABA qui est avec nous
dans le dans dans le chat qui nous
remercie de mettre en musique ce ce ce
format ben on vous remercie d'être avec
nous encore jusqu'à cette jusqu'à cette
heure d'avoir suivi avec nous euh cette
conférence de presse euh justement dans
dans les commentaires un peu plus haut
pendant la pendant la conférence de
presse j'ai vu pas mal de de
commentaires dans ce sens-là en disant
il y a beaucoup de mesures il annonce
beaucoup de choses mais tout ça ça va
finir par coûter quand même très cher
non alors il y a des mesures qui coûtent
de l'argent bah évidemment les les les
les mais on va pas lu on va pas non plus
reprocher au président de d'annoncer au
aux classes moyenne qui va avoir de 2
milliards de d'économie pour elle ça
c'est des mesures qui coûtent peut-être
cher mais qui peuvent avoir une certaine
dynamique par le fait de redonner du
pouvoir d'achat vous savez effet de
levier bien connu en économie après il y
a un certain nombre de mesures
effectivement ça le le service national
universel des choses comme ça qui
peuvent effectivement et rappelez-vous
que c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles Jacques Chirac avait supprimé
le service national c'est c'était le
coûte hein à l'époque ça coûtait 3
millions 3 milliard d'euros de de francs
mais on aurait pu traduire ça en en
euros donc c'est vrai qu'il y a un
certain nombre de de mesures qui coûtent
cher c'est tout à fait exact ce que dit
le le le téléspectateur ou l'auditeur
mais faut voir aussi les les les effets
de levier qui sont qui sont mis en place
et puis on en est que au au moment des
annonces après la mise en musique
permettra d'aborder ces questions oui et
on le disait aussi il y a eu la question
du du du référendum qui a été qui qui a
été annoncé on en parlait en avance vous
en avez parlé rapidement en introduction
mais ce référendum il a dit oui oui je
m'en servirai un jour mais toujours pas
de pas de date très très précise on va
dire
oui parce que Emmanuel Macron est
confronté au au dilemme suivant c'est
sous la 5e République et dès le général
de Gaulle le référendum a pris un
caractère plébiscitaire autrement dit
les Français appelés à se projeter sur
une une question précise notamment
l'élection au suffrage universel du
président de la République et bien a
rapidement tourné en un référendum pour
ou contre le président vous comprenez
bien que le président Macron comme tous
les autres présidents hésite à engager
un référendum par le seul fait que ce
serait ça pourrait être un plébiscite
pour lui mais on en est loin ou une
sanction ce qui serait plus probable
actuellement et donc il y a une sorte de
de de éit timoré par rapport à
l'utilisation du référendum d'autant
plus que la dernière fois en 2005 les
Français avaient voté contre la
Constitution européenne et qu'on a vu
par quel subterfuge les autorités
politiques ont finalement réussi à
revenir à une esquisse qui était proche
de celle-ci pour dans le cadre de la
construction européenne donc il est
souhaitable qu'il y ait des référendums
dans ce pays mais la prudence pour
l'instant à anime ceux qui pourrai
l'initier alors on a fait le point sur
un peu tout ce qui a été dit par
Emmanuel Macron et regardez ça c'est la
question du jour du Figaro tous les
jours Le Figaro vous pose une question
et voici la question qu'on vous pose à
la sortie de cette conférence de presse
Emmanuel Macron vous a-t-il convaincu et
vous lu gr est-ce que Emmanuel Macron
vous a convaincu moi Emmanuel Macron ne
m'a pas particulièrement convaincu car
je suis de ceux qui pensent que pour que
on puisse répondre POS ement à cette
question il faudrait qu'il prenne
vraiment des
initiatives pour le coup pas
seulement de communication mais des des
initiatives de fond voyez il aurait
annoncé ce soir un référendum permettant
vraiment de de donner la parole aux
Français sur des sujets importants pour
les Français sécurité immigration
démocratie des choses comme ça il aurait
pris une initiative cette nature là
peut-être qu'il serait il aurait redonné
un petit peu de souffle à notre
démocratie de l'espoir aux Français et
de l'espace politique pour lui-même et
donc effectivement vous plutôt non et on
va regarder les internautes sont plutôt
d'accord avec vous ils sont plus de 60 %
65 % à ne pas avoir été convaincu par
Emmanuel Macron merci beaucoup lu grin
en tout cas d'avoir été avec nous toute
cette soirée pour suivre ce cette cette
cette conférence de presse je montre en
même temps à nos internautes voilà sur
l'écran l'article du Figaro uniforme à
l'école congé de naissance RN ce qu'il
faut retenir de la conférence de presse
d'Emmanuel Macron merci à vous les
internautes d'avoir été très nombreux à
nous suivre merci une nouvelle fois
lugras d'avoir été avec nous et moi je
vous dis à bientôt pour de nouveau live
sur Figaro live et vous pouvez retrouver
toutes ces informations sur le site du
Figaro